it's kind of a crazy Friday I don't know
why Elon Musk keeps insisting on having
these Twitter files drop on the worst
possible press day at least yesterdays
was a Thursday but Thursday is also a
terrible day Tuesday is good Tuesday's
the best day Friday absolute worst like
if you put it out on Saturday then some
people will see it on Sunday but you put
on Friday it just dies the next day
everybody says no way I'm going out
getting a burger and I'm not thinking
about work but we do got big news
the latest Twitter files shows that uh
this is crazy Twitter had weekly
meetings with the feds DHS FBI over
election related issues they were
directing them and Advising them on what
to remove how to remove it you can see
these conversations happening this is
the FBI directly interfering in public
Communications pertaining to the 2020
election and banning things and you can
actually see in these releases that the
Twitter staff are are trying to figure
out how they can ban Trump who said
certain things like oh guys this thing
he said it's actually true because he
posted a story and they're like oh we
can't remember that story is actually
true I wonder how many times
they didn't actually bother to fact
check or a person made a claim not by
posting a link to a news story but
saying hey did you hear the story X and
then they go well don't can't remove it
this is crazy stuff we're getting more
and more and there is just a wall of
tweets from Matt taibi breaking down how
this all went down so we will be talking
about that we also have Elon Musk
confirming
politicians running for re-election were
Shadow banned during their election
campaign so direct election interference
FBI and law enforcement involvement and
then the craziest thing out of all of it
earlier Mike cernovich tweeted that
several trust and safety members of
Twitter who resigned should be
criminally charged because these people
refused to take down child exploitation
Elon Musk made a statement Jack Dorsey
said this is not true it's false and
then Elon responded with the receipts
that Twitter was not taking down child
exploitation I wonder why it is that
these people stayed at the company for
years with a child abuse problem and the
moment Elon comes in starts cleaning it
up they go oh I can't I can't be here
anymore I can't allow this gee I wonder
what's going through these people's
minds we got other stuff Elton John quit
maybe we'll talk about it Kirsten Cinema
has switched or she's quit the
Democratic party so there's some
political stuff involved and we'll get
into a lot of it before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
and support our work directly when you
become a member you are not just
supporting us we use parallel economy
this is a payment processor co-founded
by Dan bongino and it is censorship
resistant it's called parallel economy
we are actively seeking to build that
parallel economy to fight back against
censorship and manipulation and this is
just one path to doing it so when you
become a member you'll get access to
uncensored segments of this show Monday
through Thursday you'll get cast castle
and tales from the inverted world but
you will also be just generally
supporting this effort to construct a
parallel economy we've had some
documentaries coming out we've got a
coffee shop in the works and we've got
some other projects I will give a brief
update really quickly yesterday I
mentioned putting up a billboard in
Fredericksburg
I had a conversation with some of the
people involved and uh it would appear
that I'll just put it this way
it would not be appreciated if we did
put up a billboard calling out the
officers involved so that that's not
going to happen all right so I don't I
don't want to step on anybody's toes but
uh there you go I just want to make sure
you guys knew because I was actually
really really excited for that so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us to
talk about all of this and more is
Andrew Pollock
hey how's it going You're Gonna grab the
mic oh yeah so uh just uh introduce
yourself I'm Andrew Pollock I grew up in
Long Island
uh and I moved to Florida in about 1999.
uh been an entrepreneur
I moved to Florida in 99 with my family
and now I bounce back and forth from
Oregon to Florida and I'm happy to be on
Tim's show tonight to discuss things
that's what's going on in the country
and my past what what I've been through
in my life yeah your story is actually
pretty heartbreaking yeah uh I say one
thing I I always tell people that don't
know me or they they always mention when
they mention my daughter they mentioned
that she was lost or she died and I
always correct people uh my daughter was
murdered okay the dying is something
peaceful lost is maybe you find them
again
but murdered uh gets you know I just
feel that's the proper way to say it uh
when people are talking to me they never
know what to say and
my life's been changed ever since and
I've been on a mission for to educate
families uh to better uh equip police
departments in the country uh to respond
better
and I'm a pretty busy guy and I have two
children that live in Florida that I
love that one of them is watching or two
they're probably both watching and I'm
happy to be here with you guys and shoot
the crap for context your daughter was
lost in the Parkland I just told you we
don't say lost you're right your
daughter was murdered she was I just
don't take it the wrong way I just said
thank you I'm a little wacky but yeah
yeah uh because lost was maybe I'll find
it one day you know so she was birded in
2018 she was a senior it was horrific it
was the worst thing that could ever
happen to a parent ever
and if there's not a moment that goes by
that I don't think about my daughter and
trying to make it so another family
would never have to go through what I've
been through and that's what drives me
to come on shows and and to travel the
country and to help law enforcement
right on well thanks for joining us man
we'll get into that as well sure we also
got Luke hanging out it's a crazy story
we're definitely going to be talking
about that plus a lot more my name is
Luke ridowski here of we are change.org
today I'm wearing a t-shirt that says I
tested positive for Freedom uh my
symptoms are that I'm not a punk and I
don't believe the government should be
using force and violence to put ideas
onto other people so uh if you agree
with me and also have a case of the
freedoms you could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thank you again
so much for having me I'm Ian Crossland
thank you guys for coming thank you for
being here with me all my fellow humans
Andrew Andy good to see you buddy good
man I'm glad ready to get down to
business bro happy to be here let's rock
and roll what's happening Kellen hey
guys I'm back again again happy Friday
everybody
um yeah I'm really excited to talk about
things hash it out and definitely hear
your story right on cool so just just
another quick clarification for those
that don't understand why I wanted to
put up a billboard of those bad cops
right when I say it wouldn't be
appreciated it wouldn't be appreciated
by those who are upset with those cops
so I don't want to I don't want to give
away too much personal private
information but you know talk to people
down there and they were like nah we
shouldn't do that and I was like okay
what happened Tim what's the story
there's a story out of Virginia where a
guy
um refused the coveted lockdown uh stuff
so so two years later the cops are going
in and they're screwing with his
business he filmed the cops and then I
said let's name and shame the cops let's
put up a billboard and a lot of people
got excited for the idea I certainly was
but uh I've been requested not to do
that by people involved and not the cops
but um not respected I respect it I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna go into someone
else's town and kind of screw with them
so it's just an update but let's let's
get into the news here we got the story
this Twitter thread from Matt saibi and
it's all right here check this out
Post Number 20 of today's Twitter files
this post is about the hunter Biden
laptop situation shows that Roth yellow
Roth not only met weekly with the FBI
and DHS but with the office of the
Director of National Intelligence take a
look at this
this post the most important thing it
says in short FML weekly sync with FBI
DHS dni re-election security the meeting
happened about 15 minutes after the
aforementioned hack materials implosion
blah blah blah that right there says one
thing very very simply
Twitter was regularly meeting with
federal law enforcement for
quote-unquote election security but
Twitter was being advised that there was
going to be hacked materials and other
things like that we've we know that the
FBI contacted them specifically about
that we now know they had consistent
weekly meetings to the point where they
were actually like oh man gonna have to
meet uh miss our our weekly meet up with
federal law enforcement to figure out
what's what's not allowed this Twitter
thread is actually very very crazy
there's one post where let me see if I
can I can there's so many of these look
at this one yoel Roth said
very boring business meeting that is
definitely not about Trump pretty much
definitely not meeting with the FBI I
swear LMAO it would sound and it would
appear I'm trying to be very careful
that Joel Roth met with the FBI to
discuss Donald Trump I wonder what this
was pertaining to this Twitter thread
from Matt TYB is specifically about
banning Donald Trump he says after j6
internal slacks Show Twitter Executives
getting a kick out of intensified
relationships with federal agencies
here's Joel Roth lamenting a lack of
generic enough calendar descriptions to
concealing his very interesting meeting
Partners sounds to me like the FBI was
meeting with Twitter and uh they
colluded ultimately to come to the
decision to remove Donald Trump the
first sitting head of state to be
suspended from a platform and aside from
that the other information showing that
they were having regular 2020 election
security meetings
and we know that the FBI warned about
the hunter Biden laptop situation and
they had access to this so to me I think
this is the bare minimum confirmation
the FBI was directly interfering in the
2020 election
I mean it's pretty clear after all the
circumstantial evidence is coming
together and there's a lot of it
specifically highlighting the
involvement of this and I I kind of want
to bring back what U.S congressman Chuck
Schumer said a couple years ago in 2017
when he was directly addressing Donald
Trump When Donald Trump was having
problems with the Intel agencies with
the FBI he said quote the Intel
officials have six ways from Sunday at
getting back at you so I think it's fair
to say that there was a lot of
infighting and it's fair to say that
there was federal agencies Intel
organizations Military psyops Officers
that were working at these big Tech
social media companies there was a
revolving door between all those
institutions and a lot of these bigger
companies not just Twitter but also
Facebook also alphabet also Google and
when you look at this revolving door you
clearly see a conflict of interest
people abusing their power not just
meeting together but making big
decisions and this is what I said when
the first Twitter files were coming out
I'm like this is just bare minimum this
is still just scratching the surface as
there was a former FBI agent that was
that was critically involved in this
whole Trump collusion story that was
involved in censoring it from the very
beginning so so so now I think we're
seeing some of the layers of this onion
unravel a lot of people are going to be
crying and I I think we're still only
seeing the surface of what's a deeper
relationship between the Intel community
and of course big Tech social media that
are working hand in hand together I've
mentioned oh that it's happened before
and and that I feel like but we talk
about how like it's frog in the pot
boiling the water's boiling slowly and
we don't feel it heating up because it's
happening so slowly but think about
Nixon man the last time we had a corrupt
government spying
explosive news piece it was Nixon well
it wasn't that wasn't the last time but
Nixon and Watergate he resigned the
presidency because he was found spying
on another campaign do you remember uh
when President Trump was uh still
president there was some legislative
Bill put in to against big Tech and it
went into the Senate and they knocked it
down he warned about out all this all
the censorship and it didn't get passed
through the Senate no do you remember
that well was it it was you remember Tim
no I was going to say from 2016 to 2018
the Republicans were actively working
against Trump exactly and especially
with big Tech because I know he warned
them about it and they didn't follow
through when they could have when they
had control now you know there's no
control I'm sorry I need to clarify
they've always been working against
Trump but I mean when they had full
control of of the of the Senate and the
house they were going along with the
whole Russia gate lies and all of its
stuff check this I want to show you guys
this tweet from um Matt's Ivy check this
out
here the FBI sends reports about a pair
of tweets the second of which involves a
former typical Tippecanoe County Indiana
counselor and Republican named John
Basham claiming between 2 and 25 of
ballots by mail are being rejected for
errors
so they said
here we just got a report from the FBI
concerning two tweets related to the
shredding of mail-in ballots this has
proven to be false via this PolitiFact
do we have a moment ready for this one I
believe this was deemed no vo on
numerous occasions
so this is the FBI contacting Twitter
saying remove this guy's speech on what
grounds PolitiFact says it's not true
but on what Authority does the federal
government have to flag the speech of a
private individual to be removed from a
platform zero none period it's pure
corruption look I I don't like the idea
of misinformation I think PolitiFact is
full of Trap full of garbage they lie
all the time
the fact that partisan leftist
organizations can claim something's not
true the FBI then goes to Twitter and
Twitter says oh look at that guess we
got to remove it this is this is uh
um some people are saying collusion
other people are saying conspiracy I
think all you know all those references
could be true do they use PolitiFact as
proof they use the word this is quote
proven you don't take one news article
and use that as quote proof like you
need to you need to look around you're
gonna make a big decision like that like
ending someone's twitter experience you
got to know you can't just willy-nilly
say like
you know this piece of evidence
indicates true proof that's a big
problem they don't have the assets to do
it who doesn't the FBI they could look
into anything you know they shouldn't
just be gone by one news they don't I
think at this point
um we can clearly see the FBI is is
effectively only going after their
political enemies yeah I think what
really happened is that they saw an
article that they liked that that
verified what they wanted to be true so
they said it was proof but I mean on it
you cannot no human realistically can
look at one news article and use that as
a piece of proof for something that's
ridiculous after the uh the plethora of
crimes committed against uh us here as
well as people on our periphery if the
FBI lifted a single finger I might be
inclined to give them the benefit of the
doubt and say you know it's these bad
apples in DC but at this point
considering you've got Marjorie Taylor
green being swatted seemingly no action
we've been swatted now I think like 15
times no action and there's been other
crimes in the periphery of the work we
do with people we know and zero action
to the point where I've actually had
people say to me when we're talking
privately I can't say some of this stuff
because I'm hoping something does get
involved like something does happen with
law enforcement but I've had people say
to me like whether the FBI do anything
about that and I'm like no of course
they didn't it's been two years I mean
there's there's nothing being done so so
I will just say at this point I think
it's fair to say the FBI is not going to
do anything they'll go after a garage
pull rope for a for a NASCAR driver
that but but they're not going to deal
with the the seriousness of crimes
they're going to directly this is them
directly interfering in the election
like it is a criminal organization
obviously tell you what happened
personally to my family with the FBI
there were two tips called in to the FBI
about my daughter's shooter and they
dropped the ball on both of them wow
they didn't follow up wasn't the
shooter's gonna be a shooter was the
shooter uh a Democrat or you know it was
just a piece of garbage you know but
they called in they called it in twice
to the FBI and they dropped the ball
they ended up getting held accountable
they they're actually one of the only
entities that admitted failure in the
shooting but they also and they do and
that happens in many shootings you know
they were constantly dropping the ball
but what's their concern with Twitter
you know what I mean there's people
getting shot and and here they are
censoring and working with Twitter when
they're dropping the ball on mass
shootings you're specifically mentioning
the parking shooter is that correct
correct because we see this time and
time again known to authorities there's
so many instances where he was either
undercover or working or known to uh
local police officers state officers or
in the most situations let's be honest
here Federal officials federal
government officials especially at the
FBI uh who were warned many times and
it's just it's just mind-boggling and
and head scratching for the average
citizen to be like oh he was known again
and they and they didn't stop it but if
there's an abortion activist if there's
a parent-teacher conference activist
they're going to be on them like white
on rice they're going to be
investigating them spying on them
they're going to be jailing people just
like they are for peacefully singing
hymns outside of abortion clinics that's
what the FBI is spending their resources
on right now but but all these mass
shootings always go free when we have
the biggest national security
surveillance Dragnet and all of recorded
human history the government sees and
watches almost every aspect of our life
databases it in these huge server rooms
watches over everything and and we're
gonna we're gonna believe them when they
say oh you know this convenient event
that works towards our agenda that gives
us more power and authority now that
more people will have to rely on us on
just accidentally happened we knew you
know we knew that there was a suspect
here but he just fell through the cracks
once again and it happens over and over
I know it's crazy it's absolutely
infuriating it is were they were they
honest you said they were they came
clean and said they dropped the bubble
were they honest you about why they
dropped the ball well they it was a call
it was a couple of calls and they didn't
follow up on the call and they admitted
to it and a lot of guys and they said
they made changes I didn't find out what
exactly happened to the uh
the police saw the FBI agents that
didn't follow up and a lot of the times
it's it's the same Mo it's someone who's
socially isolated someone who hurts
themselves and hurts other people around
them someone who clearly is a threat
someone who even goes online and says
I'm going to be committing these threats
and that also falls through the cracks I
mean there's just so many of these I
have the lady that called the threat
into the FBI that calls me like
constantly you know not constantly every
few months she checks in with me because
she just feels horrible yeah that she
called and warned them and they never
followed up on it you're someone that
knew the guy personally yeah it was like
an aunt the distant ant that knew he was
you know talking about being a school
shooter and she had called the FBI and
the police department and they didn't
follow up correctly and the rest you
know we know what happened
because she knew something was going to
happen she tried to warn the authorities
and then they just sat on their hands
didn't do it and you know we uh you guys
don't follow it as much as I do we just
had that trial he just and after
murdering 17 people uh he still wasn't
committed he didn't get the death
penalty life without parole you know he
said we killed 17 people innocent on
video admitted to it and didn't get the
death penalty I know it's ridiculous why
no death penalty a couple it was like
one or two people voted against the
death penalty in the jury so we're
trying to fix that I've been I spoke
with Governor DeSantis about it there's
a way around it where you you don't need
a full majority uh it could be less it
could be like 70 percent because it was
ridiculous what does a person need to do
in society to get the death penalty if
this thing didn't get it did you sell my
daughter would you support the death
penalty before the shooting well I have
a I personally have a problem with the
way that that penalty works because the
average death row inmate sits there for
20 years before they're executed
peacefully
so I think there could be a lot of
changes to it it should be expedited you
know someone commits a heinous crime
like that it should shouldn't take more
than six months you know to have a trial
and execute them then I would be all for
the death penalty but the way it's set
up now with appeals and they get their
own uh
I looked into it so a death row inmate
doesn't have to work when he's in prison
he doesn't have to get his meals it's
brought to him he gets his own TV he
gets his own security detail so death
row a lot of people after a few years of
being a general population are actually
praying to be on death row that's what
I'm hoping happens to my daughter's
killer all of them on death row are
getting fed meals and they they're
brought to the meals are brought to them
what you know by the correction officers
they don't have to go on a line they
don't have to go on a general population
they have their own security detail
their own TV their own computer and they
just sit most of them it's over 20 years
we talk about the ethics of the death
penalty on the show from time to time
I'm kind of it's uh it's interesting
because I'm like pro-choice but Pro
death penalty maybe I'm just a killer
well we'll kill us in a way but I would
be more forward if it was on the 20
years you know to sit 20 years is in a
cell and it's cost you know Broward
County where he was housed it cost the
county four million dollars just keeping
them in the prison system awaiting trial
in Canada they banned the death penalty
but they they're expanding their
euthanasia efforts very aggressively
which is absolutely mind-boggling and
and absolutely totally backwards in my
opinion but if you don't mind telling us
about this a little bit more details
about this FBI story because again it's
either they miss it or they're either
trying to find someone who's mentally
ill and goading them into doing
something as there's also a lot of
documented stories of people coming
together saying hey I had a mentally ill
child the FBI worked undercover and
tried to push them to be extremists
there's a lot of those stories as well
but what did this woman do you have some
of the details here I know you don't
have a lot of the notes in front of you
but but there was two warnings uh one
was uh from like a chat room the first
one came from someone in a chat room to
the FBI and the other one was from like
an aunt of his to call on the FBI that
he was going to be a school shooter wow
and they failed both uh you know both of
them they didn't follow up yeah uh the
police and the sheriff's department
didn't follow up either what's pretty
bad is there was this guy here Deputy
Eason his name was I I remembered his
names he got called the follow-up that
he was going to be the school shooter he
doesn't go and follow up on the tip
right so
of course he was able to go and kill my
daughter that day but he's also one of
the deputies that went to the school and
didn't go in the building that wow you
know so he failed miserably not
following up the lead and then he goes
to the high school and lets kids get
killed inside a building just doesn't go
in would have gone in a vest it's
outside just like Uvaldi
um
the same kind of stories officers
outside this is so like frustrating and
so heartbreaking to hear all the time
officers standing outside not really not
going to affected me big time with
Uvaldi because I I was so after the
Parkland shooting I got so involved with
law enforcement and we made such a stink
out of that there was just the one
Deputy at the school his name was Deputy
Peterson Scott he didn't go in that day
he hid for 45 minutes he didn't hide he
was right by the he went within eight
feet of the door he heard the AR shots
going off I know all this from uh
depositions we did he heard the arc
shots going off and he went to reach and
then he heard it he retreated and then
he hid behind he stared by a wall
for 45 minutes why he heard the gunshots
going off
so he is a lot of people don't notice
but he is being held on felony uh child
endangerment charges I'll be at his
trial it'll be in May but after Parkland
it was there was so much media attention
on these cops not going in and I did so
much press that I thought there's no way
in the world what could a cop not know
if you hear gunshots that you gotta move
towards the gunfire and then you've
already happened and it really killed me
and my son had issues you know with the
anxiety and it was just horrible after
evaldi that these guys I don't know if
you noticed they didn't even go to open
the door in Uvalde you know it wasn't
locked that was all Bs they created a
perimeter blocking parents pushing
parents out so they couldn't stop the
shooting there was parents that had to
that were arrested they had to run away
and then get in the building and then
get their children before the cops did
in Uvalde which is infuriating and
there's and and I remember carvering
Parkland and and reading about it and
being like what were these cops thinking
their arms there's a number of them
they're inside of a school their main
job is to is to you know as they say
Protect and serve their main job is to
run into the line
of fire when it comes to safeguarding
the most innocent the most smallest the
most the purest you know children of our
society and then they they just chilled
and killed what was that uh that that we
were talking about I think earlier this
week how in China if someone's driving a
car and they accidentally run someone
over
they'll get out of the car and then
murder the person because having to be
financially responsible for a person for
life is worse than getting a few years
in prison for an accidental like you
know vehicular assault or whatever when
there was there was another another
story people uh I can't remember who
brought it up about uh what they do in
China in a similar fashion but when you
get to a point where your Society is
over overly litigious and lacking any
kind of social cohesion these are the
stories we start to see the reason why
the cops and Uvalde bar parents from
going in I don't want to get sued if
they go in there and cause a problem
they're going to say why didn't the
police stop them from going in and then
we get sued and then I lose my job no
you're not allowed to go in I'm not
gonna go in either you want me to risk
my life for your kid never gonna happen
that's where we're at right now people
don't look at each other and say we're
all in this together they look at it and
say every man for himself was that the
vibe you got I'm not that you know the
intentions of the officers on duty at
the time but did you get the vibe that
they didn't want to get legal recourse
or were they just afraid or they would
just uh there's an expression in law
enforcement it's called Rod retired on
duty Parklands listed as one of the
safest cities in the state so they just
had cushy jobs overweight cops you know
uh they didn't run in where anyone the
coaches they were coaches at the school
that ran in that day unarmed and so
Deputy Peterson now he's getting a
hundred and ten thousand a year pension
for letting my daughter get murdered and
those other 16 people so I'm hoping I'll
be at that trial in May in Broward and
I'm hoping if he's found guilty of
felony charges uh he'll lose his pension
he went and was crazy it was
unbelievable we had we deposed them you
know and I was sitting as close as I am
to Tim with this guy and he came in
holding a Bible you know he thinks he's
gonna God's Gonna help him now that he
let all those people die it's nice to
hear that you said the coaches actually
ran in that day because you know I'm
actually a high school coach myself and
they tell you you can't like if there's
fights you can't touch the kids like Tim
was saying like out of fear of lawsuits
so I'm glad the the coaches of Parkland
actually had they wanted to go in and go
and his theme was uh Aaron Feist and
they actually named the really good
program after him in in Florida it's
called the Aaron Feist Guardian program
where teachers or not law enforcement
could go through this program and be
able to carry on at the schools and I I
sat through it it's really intense and
there's different districts that are
allowing it and they named it in the
bill that we got passed in Florida the
Aaron Feist Guardian program Aaron died
shielding stew this I'm reading about it
yep what was it happened exactly oh he
got it he went into the building uh and
it was just horrible timing went exactly
when he opened the door he was he just
blown away with the gut with the shooter
my daughter actually was uh on the ninth
floor she was uh shot nine times and she
was Shield she shielded another student
and actually at Point Blank Range he
shot her and the bullets went through
her and killed the other girl too so for
45 minutes to an hour the police were
sitting outside five minutes well one
guy with an AR well multiple weapons was
walking around the school one AR that he
had an AR at the Peterson the deputy
that was there could have had a clear
shot at him uh he he went to the door
the shooter was still on the first floor
people a lot of people don't know the
shooter went to the school in an Uber if
you could believe it with the Cabela's
rifle bag she picked them up at his
house the Uber driver drove him to the
school with his rifle bag where he got
out and walked right in through an open
gate where the gate wasn't again was
against protocol the gate should have
been locked
you know that and you know people didn't
call the code red
people hidden adults had hidden closets
didn't you know didn't call a code red
police hit there was like so many things
that went wrong against my daughter that
day that I could make a list what if
just what if certain things would have
happened she'd be alive today or do they
have gun free zones in these in these
places I think every school's like yeah
most of them because I'm wondering about
an Uber driver seeing someone come with
a rifle bag and being like Oh it's cool
you say huh and driving them into this
place where there's you know I guess my
view of it is the law gun free zone is
is it is meaningless oh well people
criminals don't follow gun free zones
but even Uber drivers don't understand
yeah you know they're they're they will
pick up a person with a gun and drive
them right yeah with the rifle big
carried it with the Cabela's rifle bag
right into the school and doesn't never
said anything they thought it was normal
to pick up a kid before school hours no
one's even there you know it was just
one of the things that went against my
daughter that day so what what do you
think it sounds like the people who were
armed were the people who shouldn't have
been and the people who should have been
weren't armed yeah the coaches but now
with certain districts or coaches could
go get from what happened a coach can
now go and go through this Guardian
program and be able to carry on campus
but it's foreign not all can't you know
it depends on the county you know if you
live in a conservative County like I'm
going to uh in January the
superintendent's going to be carrying an
AR pistol
you know that's up in Bradford County
where I'm doing some things with law
enforcement so I I hear a lot from these
uh Democrat establishment gun control
types they think that it's nightmarish
this idea that teachers would be armed
that we would have special law
enforcement armed in these schools but
the crazy thing is if you go back in
time they had gun clubs at high schools
clubs Red Rifle clubs people had people
had guns people were armed and then we
slowly started Banning them now the idea
of just going back to the way things
used to be is shocking like oh how could
we but I don't know I'm curious your
thoughts what do you think I mean well
the problem really with the lot of these
shootings what Democrats focus on gun
control before they even know the facts
like the kid could have been cutting
animals up in his backyard threatening
to kill people rape people but they
don't look into any of the failures
before or prior you know you need to see
what happened before to prevent things
from happening in the future so
Democrats when they focus just on gun
control it it doesn't solve a thing but
that's one thing I could say really what
would happen in Florida under it was
governor Scott at the time he formed the
the Marjory Stoneman
safety commission and I was on it and
some friends and uh other fathers that
had kids killed and deputies and
sheriffs and lawyers and they dissected
everything that happened in Parkland and
they made changes in the whole state and
Ron DeSantis who I'm friends with he
actually he put He removed the sheriff
he was unbelievable the guy he removed
that failed Sheriff the first month in
office Ron came down I got a call from
him he goes Andy we're going to remove
that sheriff uh and I go what how are
you going to do that he goes well I'm
just going to remove them I'll be in
Tallahassee I go no Governor you need to
come down to Broward go right in his
office and you You Yank that guy right
out of right it was so great he came
flew down the Broward he had the
emergency landing on the way down
he's so he's like Alice we're waiting
like everyone's waiting at the Sheriff's
Office and he came down and he removed
the sheriff within the first month that
was like national news that he got rid
of him you know he was the guy that was
on CNN talking about his amazing
leadership wow he's actually so and he
ran again Broward is such a cesspool so
he actually ran again for office and
almost won that's how bad Broward how
blue and evil Broward county is what do
you think about the uh these kids who
got really famous from uh what happened
in Parkland they started becoming uh I
think for the most part the media props
up this bunch of this group of young
people who are very much gun control
activists yeah but then you had uh Kyle
uh Kashif I'm probably pronouncing your
name wrong Kyle who is more Pro 2A I'm
curious your thoughts on you know how
the media handled it well like I said
they focused on just the gun control and
they didn't accomplish anything but
registered Democrats that's all those
kids accomplished when it came time for
running School Board Races they were
nowhere to be seen when it came time to
get rid of the sheriff nowhere to be
seen getting bills passed Common Sense
bills for school safety there were
nowhere to be seen but me and other
couple of parents and my family my sons
we were at it like non-stop to hold
people accountable uh Ron I call him Ron
I should people don't know him but go by
Governor DeSantis actually after we
removed him he put a grand jury
investigation into the Broward County
school board and just recently within
the last six months four school board
members were removed wow and the
superintendent was arrested so there's
been like when you really want to make a
difference and you go for accountability
you could make a difference yeah Ron
really got involved on the local level
especially when it came to Local School
Board elections and a lot of people are
saying that he did a really good job how
would you rank his kind of response to
everything that happened in Parkland he
did unbelievable for my family and
myself for accountability you know
getting the the superintendent arrested
on felony charges you know Broward is so
bad that so the superintendent gets
arrested right on felony perjury charges
through the grand jury wouldn't you know
that same year they had that in Broward
they had that superintendent speak at
the school when my daughter was murdered
at graduation that's how bad these these
people are on Broward so he got that
done four school board members he
cleaned house and the deputy was
arrested and and the sheriff was removed
and he just did like where could that
ever happen where I could tell you that
I met him and he told me he was going to
hold these people accountable and and we
did we we removed them all they got
arrested they were on charges the city
uh the school board lawyer was arrested
so the media doesn't tell the rest of
the country what really happened they
don't want to focus they're on to the
next mass shooting and they're going to
blame that Black Rifle and then they'll
move on to the next one that's where
they they get all their attention you
know we we on this show we talk about a
lot of the problems that are going we
open up the show with discussing you
know FBI interference and elections and
stuff and it very much feels like we're
constantly pushing this Boulder uphill
endlessly pushing back against this
but for your story and what we've seen
with with similar stories it's not just
pushing a boulder uphill it's like being
on fire at the same time where
something's so devastating so
destructive to your life this problem
that you've not only experienced the
pain you've experienced but you see the
solutions you want the solutions I can't
imagine what it must be like to have
people
working against you these political
forces that we complain about I couldn't
imagine being in your situation well the
worst one of the worst well my daughter
getting murdered that tops everything
but that day my daughter got murdered I
had a trump 2020 shirt on
and some report I was waiting at the
hospital praying that my daughter was
alive takes a picture of my trump shirt
and the hate that I got even what my
daughter like the people were blaming me
for my daughter getting killed on social
media because I had a trump 2020 shirt
on
so
you know
there's a lot of things that I've been
working on uh to try and prevent these
shootings
and working with law enforcement one
thing I'd like to tell you guys that one
of the biggest problems that Society
doesn't realize because you talk about
Mental Health
it's such a failed system uh the mental
health uh treatment in this country and
what happens to these people that are
mentally ill and I know this factually
because my wife is an ER physician so
she constantly sees mentally ill people
coming into the hospital what happens
with these mentally ill people is
the police pick them up they threaten to
shoot the neighbor they they run a dog
over they kill a cat or they they
they're threatening the rape people the
police just use the hospital as dumping
grounds uh it doesn't get put on their
background whether they threaten to kill
10 people blow up a building they go
right through the system they drop them
off at the hospital they're out in 24
hours with no background so they can
make Democrats can make all the laws
they want you know for backgrounds and
so you can't buy a rifle but if someone
who's mentally ill or criminal doesn't
get a background all the gun laws in the
in the country are never going to
prevent it yeah and it's not just that I
I think it's also fair to say that a lot
of these people just get thrown pills
specifically ssris I don't know if you
heard that conversation or have any kind
of understanding of it from a lot of
these kind of sickos who just get thrown
these pills that mess up their brain
chemistry
um do you have any knowledge of that and
was that related to Parkland as well uh
he was on those type of medications but
there's so many kids that are on it that
don't commit these crimes like there's
kids that play violent video games you
know and don't go out and kill people so
there's I I've heard of that and I and
the one that uh my daughter's murderer
was on those types of medications
yeah it was like ssris do you know the
name of the name of them I forget okay
yeah well a lot of them you know that's
usually one of the common connections
between a lot of these kind of lunatics
um is that you know they go on some of
these medications and it just kind of
makes them go crazy again correlation
does not mean causation a lot of people
like to stretch and just say it's fully
that I think there's a lot of failures
in our society especially when it comes
to fatherless homes especially when it
comes to the medical industry especially
when it comes to law enforcement I mean
there's so many things that we could
address when it comes to the rising
amount of gun violence in this country
um you know which one do you think is
maybe more prominent I think the worst
is the mentally ill not getting the
background you know when they do
something that that deserves it they
just go like there's this what's called
The Baker Act in Florida that if you get
committed and you go through the full
Baker Act where you've put in front of a
judge and a psychiatrist it'll go on
your background but 99.9 percent of that
never happens they just get released and
that's you know the failure there's no
more mental institutions so you take
away if you take you take away 50 of the
mass shootings probably in the country
if the mentally ill that really a
violent you know you have to be careful
there they have to have due process and
and if they had a background on them
they wouldn't be able to purchase do you
think that uh decline in religion plays
a role in a lot of the stuff that and
the fatherless home like you you've said
you know the lat you know families look
with inflation now look what parents
have to do just to stay afloat man even
if there are two parents you know they
work in you know they're working you
know just to be able to afford a dozen
eggs now you know the price of
everything food gas apparent you know
years ago my mom stayed home you know
when I was growing up how many parents
now have that ability where they don't
need a two-parent two parents working
so it is a problem in society
people looking at me like I'm I got some
wisdom
I'm trying to find out what drug the guy
was on I couldn't figure it out I think
a big part of it is it really wasn't
focusing on the drugs you know because
they want they wanted the death penalty
you know so they're not gonna they don't
want any outs with any drugs or any
mental illness you know I I asked about
the you know religion but it's not just
about religion it's about a cohesive
cultural structure it's everything it's
all the whole family unit right I see is
struggling and uh you know I couldn't
help but to notice too because you know
Ian's copy of genderqueer is sitting
next to you you're familiar with that
old controversy uh not I don't follow it
that much but I know we can't follow it
with the sports and stuff men competing
in women's sports and different
bathrooms and genders this book is in
grade schools and I can't show you
what's in it because it's a violation of
Twitter's I'm sorry of Twitter of
YouTube's rules to show the content
that's in that book that's awesome it's
a graphic content that they're having
kids well see and this is this is a
component I just just I don't want to
sure but the governor in Florida was
attacked for just they put this bill in
place I don't you guys must have heard
it what they they wanted to make it to
don't say gay Bill really education but
really it was uh the teachers have no
right teaching anything about sexuality
and kindergarten first grade and second
grade and that's all it was and they
attacked the guy like what parent would
want you to send in your child to school
and kindergarten they're talking about
and then they like their identity yeah
and then they lied about it they said it
was the don't say gay Bill there was
nothing in there not about that at all
they just wanted to attack them exactly
and then the national media and the
Democratic Party All March in lockstep
saying anybody who brings it up is lying
about it including Disney that's right
what the hectic why is the guy even
saying anything and then but what's
great is so the governor DeSantis went
at Disney they were getting all these
special tax breaks for being a Florida
Corp and he pulled them all from them so
now they're like paying like he's doing
very Savage the guy is a Savage interest
he's a great guy well so you know I
bring this up because the stuff we're
seeing in schools the decline uh I
should say the rise of secularism and
the decline of religion all seem to be
components in not just
shootings at schools shootings in in
cities a rise in violent crime in all
the major cities but also an
unwillingness from people in the
community to actually try to save each
other
so uh you know talking about having a
Parkland talking about hat with Uvaldi
like I said it's it's kind of like what
we see with communist China these cops
are like you can't go in I'll get sued
and I'm not going to save them because I
don't care about you I don't know who
you are and you don't mean anything to
me well it it depends you know it's a
serious thing you know I get a lot of
calls from parents and emails about
their children in the schools and what's
going on about everything gen their
identity security what they're teaching
in the schools restorative justice
programs and my first answer to them is
because I it's really painful I can't
answer everybody about their kid getting
bullied or another kid getting murdered
but the quickest response would be if
you could afford it you send your kid to
private school when did you guys ever
hear of the last school shooting that
was at a private school you never hear
about it and if you can't afford private
school you home school or you move to a
district with it that's not going on
homeschooling has been increasing
dramatically but I think that latest
project Veritas video came from a very
elite private school where people are
spending about thirty to forty thousand
dollars a kid per year and they have
teachers there that are doing
unspeakable things that if we mentioned
here on this YouTube channel we would
get cut off automatically we can we can
yeah let's put it this way project
Veritas put on an expose where the dean
of students said that they pass around
adult toys and discuss the difference
between lube and spit and just and and
instruct the children on how to insert
these things into their bodies and this
is an elite uh private high school with
14 year olds being uh told this what's
the school name
um I'm gonna have to double Francis or
something Francis park or something like
that Francis W Park well it goes back to
like every Community the parents have
the power to make a change with their
elections and it all starts like you've
mentioned the School Board elections are
more important than who's living in the
white house but you look at what's
happening it's all tied together when we
see the economy start imploding these
parents don't have time to go to these
meetings they got to work two jobs and
they got to work two jobs each so now
you don't got parents who can be at home
with their kids this is breaking up the
family then they're using the schools as
daycare centers also bad for the family
then you get teachers who are trying to
subvert the parents guidance like what
we saw in Florida resulting in Ron
DeSantis you know pushing along with
along with Republicans the parental
rights and education
you actually see now the craziest thing
out of Chicago with this private school
forty thousand dollars a year
this guy on camera is saying it's really
cool that he gets to do this and when
Veritas exposed them for showing
children young young kids these these
adult objects at describing their use
and insertion the school defended the
dean the school insulted
defamed Veritas in my opinion said that
they were malicious
actively defending the depraved behavior
when that's the power of the parents you
know who would send their child to a
school like that take your kid out of
that school and make them go bankrupt
it's only because of project Veritas
that they might know because they're
working the economy is in the gutter
what are you supposed to do you go to
work and you pray that your kids are and
both parents are working right so the
family is being gutted and destroyed and
it's affecting like you said crime
shootings uh kids taking drugs fentanyl
it's all it floats it starts at the
bottom you know plus social media uh
influencing the minds of children early
on parents just giving a phone to to
children and then they're in the hands
of social media that is essentially
creating a a a kind of thought control
where their curated particular content
that they want them to see you add that
with a horrible diet you add that with
people not having you know the right gut
the right brain working uh correctly
it's a recipe for a disaster and I think
we're going to be seeing a lot more
violent events especially with the
increase in poverty especially with the
increase of fatherless homes I think
it's almost guaranteed that there's
going to be a lot more shootings a lot
more violent acts with children coming
our way because there's all their all
the ingredients are there and there's
nothing taking away from this larger uh
problem that I don't I think is sadly
unavoidable right I hear all this and
I'm saying to myself how fortunate it
was to grow up in the 80s yeah and party
like a rock star my biggest worry was
like where was the party that week and
where we're gonna go get a cold keg of
Budweiser oh even though that and the
90s it was just so incredible and I see
these kids now and it's such a
difference you know they're glued to the
phones glued to the cell phone we're all
having addiction with it you know and
it's just so much different than when I
grew up and you know we went on beer
runs in high school and we just had a
good time and we didn't have all you'd
ever heard of a school shooting you know
that's just horrible the next 10 years
it's it's going to get more interesting
Than People realize right we start the
show talking about the these uh these
Twitter files you've got talk about
censorship manipulation we've got a
breakdown of the family but right now
those kids you mentioned that are
addicted to those phones that are
growing up in these strange times 10
years old let's say in 10 years they're
going to be voting and how do you think
they're going to yeah we know affect the
political system what's happening to
particularly young girls they go on
Instagram they go on Snapchat they go on
Tick Tock and they get depressed when
they don't get enough likes on their
posts views on their videos and it's
causing a massive spike in depression
alongside kovid and all the crazy masks
that's happening we are going to have
two generations gen Z and Alpha and the
Next Generation and the next they're
going to be so negatively impacted by
this I fear that you know I I hope that
we're headed towards something better
right when we get these exposes on
Twitter and FBI it's it's shining a
light in the darkness it's sending a
signal to people that Victory Is
Possible Republicans take the house
maybe we'll see some changes but when
you start thinking about demographics
and what's happening with the young
people it may be inevitable that as the
older generation the Boomers and the
older Gen X start aging out retiring
they're not voting they're passing on we
lose that level of stability despite
look I think the greatest generation was
just that I think the boomer generation
has some issues gen xers have a little
bit more Millennials have a lot more gen
Z is going to have way more and it's
just this Cascade effect of generations
getting worse and worse and worse I fear
that for all for all the issues we can
complain about with Boomers
when the boomers are are gone it's going
to be apocalyptic you're like we we need
that level of stability among them
despite the the criticisms the younger
Generations have same thing is true for
Gen X Millennials are a psychotic
generation it's split down the middle
between woke insanity and then you've
got classically liberal to conservatives
countering that gen Z is going to be
crazy your Alpha is going to be crazier
these kids who are addicted to these
machines who have no sense of family who
who don't know their dads or or haven't
seen their families because they've been
raised by the state when they get in the
vote I think the system just implodes
and you can see now uh it's the biggest
generation of kids that are still living
home in a parent's basement you know
yeah most of not that I'm knocking that
I got a son that's still living home but
then I don't have that many economic
opportunities compared to what people
had before financial situation yeah no I
was in business by the time I was 19 I
moved out when I was 18. I was rocking
and rolling like in New York how old are
you 56 56. so is it what is that Gen X
or is that Boomer I couldn't tell you
that's one of the two it's like might be
might be 50 people I'm on the cusp maybe
I got both a little bit more 57 was that
the year you were born 56 66 66 yeah so
I think that's I think that's I think
that's a that's one more generation
earlier early early oh you're late
Boomer like maybe I'm a boomer I don't
know I'm late I call that well so you
you see what the the Gen Z the meme okay
Boomer like dismissive of this they're
growing up you're seeing a lot of
socialism why these kids don't have jobs
they go to school at school you're told
what to do don't push back we give you
your food we give you your books then
they go to college these are these are
young people who never had a job I'm not
saying not like every gen Z person has
never had a job I'm saying there's a
there's a generation
in this generation is a large swath of
young people they're now 22 years old
getting out of college and never worked
a job in their lives how are they going
to enter the workforce they can't they
end up going to places like Twitter
where they walk in and have red wine on
tap and they go to the Lego room where
they can do building blocks then they
have the meditation room because they're
just so stressed out and they think
these mean words on the online are pure
violence yo
I'm not I'm not excited about where this
country is going because we're losing
the the generation that are like I
started a business when I was 18 and
we're gaining the people who are like I
went to school till I was 28 and don't
know how to and it's pretty amazing that
everyone I grew up like all my good
friends we did one of them went to
college became a pilot but all the
others are like ones in construction
one's in tile one's a contract the one's
in the jewelry business we all did very
well for ourselves and I'm hoping that
it continues but you're not really
seeing it like you're saying I'm not
hopeful I mean do the people my peers
they're always complaining they don't
want to work they're unmotivated they're
lazy and they're sad
it's it's
yeah I'll tell you I live on a ranch out
in Oregon and there there's this one
college I respect the I have these
neighbors these kids they're about 30
years old about your guy's age and they
all went to this Oregon uh Technical
Institute in Klamath Falls and they all
came out with a profession once a dental
hygienist the other one does sonograms
and then there's all engineers and
they're all good kids man they were all
conservative kids they're not on their
phones like I hang I hang out with these
kids that down the street and they that
they're just really good solid kids so
it gives me some hope but they're so
outnumbered these kids and they all are
working or doing something they're all
and they all got great professions from
this one college but they're in the
they're in the minority right speaking
up and speaking out is a key uh it
requires a lot of I mean it's you could
argue like LOL is that really that much
work you're on a TV show talking but
like you know physically I'm not ex I'm
mentally exhausted but we just need
people to be honest in public the more
people from Gen X that are honest in
public I blame my own generation I see a
lot of my old friends from high school
just like floating just waiting until
they die basically enjoying the fruits
of what our grandfathers did for us yeah
well you know Klaus Schwab said you will
own nothing and you will be happy that's
the plan that they have implemented
that's essentially what where we're
headed towards and the society that
we're we're at but people aren't happy
they're just drugged up that's the point
they're making marijuana legal
everywhere that can't be helping all
these kids smoking weed every day
overdosing if any drug is a problem
alcohol too that's okay one that's
Insidious in our society I think South
Park put it uh really well when they
South Park did an episode on pot and
then uh it was actually funny it's they
hired this company where people pretend
to be their kids from the future and
their their drug addled losers who are
like you don't want to smoke behind me
and look at me and then you know the
kids are not stupid and they're like
this is ridiculous we don't believe it
then at the end Stan's dad says look we
just don't want you smoking marijuana
and he's like why don't you just be
honest with me and he's like well son
the truth is marijuana makes you okay
with being bored and then when you're
older you'll find that you're not good
at anything and that was just like the
simplest explanation of when kids are
out partying and drinking it doesn't
matter if it's pot or anything else
without Direction without discipline
without stability they end up you know
as young adults with no capabilities so
they have no Mission they have no Drive
they have no skills and they're angry
why can't I buy that new car why can't I
get a nice why is life so hard for me
and it's like well you spent your
teenage years doing nothing you know for
for the people who are successful like
you you said you started you were in a
business when you were 19. yeah
well I don't know what what's the answer
then you guys are younger than me what
are we going to do family generation uh
family religion maybe I've been thinking
a lot about finding peace with the past
that's a big part of it for everybody
for people in general just fine accept
what happened and then prophesy good
things for the future because sometimes
what we'll do is we'll look at the past
and then say because that happened
because there's so much it indicates
that it will happen again but we are
basic we are offering our versions of
the future to the world so you know Tim
mentions religion and there's one thing
I I I'm in a circle with some religious
Jews there Chabad and my rabbi's a
Chabad Rabbi they really do something
right they they honor the Sabbath so
every Friday which is great for the
family I I wish I did it with my kids so
everyone should do it Friday come
Sundown they shut everything down the
phones the TV everything all the family
gets together Friday night they pray
they have a big Dana they have some
drinks they chill out all the way till
Saturday Sundown how much better would
Society be if every family did that you
know what and it's really one diet
several respected and what else is this
is what a lot of people attribute to a
lot of the success uh you know so
there's most epic things about Islam is
fasting I I've been looking into the
tenets of Islam there's five pillars and
one of them is Ramadan it's this
month-long scorching heat Ramadan means
scorching heat when they lived in the
ninth month of the year like September
and they just had to live under the
burning Sun so they were fasting to
survive because if you eat in the
burning Sun you're gonna burn and uh now
in solidarity with those that did it to
survive people will Fast for a month
straight but man clearing out your gut
because like you were saying earlier
Luke it's another type of brain and it
will get closer yeah and it's being
ruined uh you know deliberately I think
that's a fantastic offering from Islam
is fasting one of the things that we've
been working on is uh I call it Saturday
morning cartoons there are a lot of
people that don't have that Sabbath
where Friday night they stay with their
families and they have dinner and
there's a lot of people that don't go to
church so what we want to do is Saturday
morning we got it we got a new location
we're setting up it's gonna be a public
uh we're gonna do Cafe on the first
floor games and stuff uh skate shop
maybe second floor and uh Saturday
morning you come in you bring the family
and the kids will watch cartoons that
are not degenerate or you know like
they'll be normal fun watch bugs Bonnie
you know like I don't mind Bugs Bunny
show show Elmer Fudd walking around with
a double barrel you know trying to hunt
ducks or whatever I got no issue with
that but there's there's cartoons that I
think uh kids could watch I mean the
stuff I grew up with I think uh in the
90s wasn't so bad but now you got really
really weird stuff like uh Blues Clues
had like one episode where it showed a
beaver with double mastectomy scars and
like you know so so we want to create a
space where parents can come in the
morning everybody can meet each other
people who live nearby can become
friends we can build community because
the reason I say religion is not because
I think you know I'm not an overly
religious person I don't think the
solution necessarily is that people need
to find God people need to find each
other religion is one method ISM for
that when people used to go to church
they'd be with their Community once a
week they would talk with each other
they would learn what's going on in the
community with uh with uh Shabbat dinner
you've got families sticking together
cutting everything out saying no no
we're here together as a family
strengthening the family unit all of
that leads to success family that prays
together stays together that's true
always hard to hurt that have you been
absorbing any of the Shabbat goodness
yeah I really love it uh whenever I'm in
town I go to my rabbi's house uh and I
just shut it down you know a lot of
times my sons will come with me and
we'll just sit with the rabbi and he
talks gives you a little Torah
uh something you know he'll give you a
Torah story and I have a rabbi in uh
Ashland when I go when I'm in Oregon
that'll hit up his house or the temple
once in a while for the holidays but
it's important they always stay in touch
with me uh we built through my
Foundation we built two playgrounds so I
was able to raise money and we built the
playground in Florida and Coral Springs
at the temple and I built one in Ashland
also what do they look like just cool
little playgrounds for kids to play and
have fun you know like swing swinging
ropes and stuff yeah if we got a slide
you got a swing you got something you
know the kids hit the drum you know they
love all that stuff but through my
Foundation of raising money we were able
to do that for the temples and I enjoy
going I think it's like Tim mentioned a
few times it's very important a family
staying together and doing things like
that even if you know not so much
religion but it's the getting together
and just being with your family this is
why I think they shut the churches down
during a code pandemic Walmart was
allowed small businesses weren't
churches weren't Parks not Florida
though they shut down the playgrounds
my Rabbi made sure to thank them when we
were at a rally recently uh with the
governor and uh my that was one of the
biggest things what my Rabbi was so
happy and to thank the governor for was
keeping the place of religion so people
could come and pray it meant a lot to
him and he wanted to make sure he
thanked the governor people don't
understand how big that was especially
when huge even the federal government
was saying you got to lock down what
Sweden is doing is wrong and that was
from the Trump Administration which is
absolutely insane so I I think truly
with so much pressure from the federal
government from the corporate media on
Florida specifically there was other
states that also didn't lock down but
specifically Florida was where everyone
was pointing to criticizing saying this
is going to be the bloodbath they're
going everyone's gonna be dead here
everyone's gonna die they have such a
big elderly population it's it's a given
everyone's dying here DeSantis is a
murderer and the Santa said no I'm gonna
not bow down to your emotional extortion
and I think truly it was Florida
standing up against all these pressures
that allowed the United States to not be
as Draconian as a lot of people planned
it to be and what was interesting all
the people from the Northeast that moved
down to Florida and they turned out
voting Republican as you saw in the
election he won like 20 basis points or
something like that like a record right
he won by yeah I relocated there I moved
down to Florida because yeah my
residencies in Florida I'll never give
it up yeah oh so yeah it's back and
forth but majority I'm in Florida and
that's where I vote that's the first
thing the governor asked me when you see
me he didn't change residency did you go
no don't worry Iran I'm voting for you
you got it you know we had a dolly form
it was great double-digit Victory what
did he win by a million votes 1.5 or 1.6
was like we almost got stuck with that
other guy Gillum if you guys remember
yes caught in a hotel room yep naked gay
prostitutes and drugs he almost won it
you know that's how terrible it was
Florida it's amazing how Florida went
from being a swing state to so Republic
it's so red it's one of the reddest
States everyone that in the state that's
running something that's Republican so
there's
um I'm gonna I'm gonna butcher this so
uh Prager I apologize what is it cut
flower politics I I think he calls it
was that what it was I think so yeah he
says that um you have this beautiful
flower in a pot and then you pick it and
hold it up and show how beautiful it is
but then as it's been separated from its
roots it slowly Withers and dies and
that's what we're dealing with now as a
society we
I feel like right now we don't realize
the wave has already hit in this country
as as we believe it doesn't exist
anymore we talk about the FBI they
they're seemingly only going after
enemies of their of their tribal
ideology so a garage Paul rope 12 agents
but uh someone's you know a bunch of
people showing up to the Supreme Court
Justices Holmes illegally protesting ah
we're not getting involved in that
pro-life activists however gotta track
them down lock them up January 6th two
years solitary no trial mass shooting
still like shootings they dropped the
bull I mean look at that there's a meme
of from a member remember on The
Simpsons episode where Bart says was it
woozle wazzle or something like that no
no no I didn't do it is that what the
line was I don't remember but he gets a
catchphrase and then all the students
look and turn to him and they say say
the line Bart the meme is he goes it's
like he's got the FBI hat and he goes
the suspect was known to us and we took
no action and then they're like Yay
because it's happened so many times we
could only hope that the house now could
do something you know maybe they'll look
into it because if they don't know who's
going to do it even the Department of
Justice you know they're all they do
whatever they want well this is the
issue the reason I bring up The Cut
Flower politics idea
the flower is dying and there's no
reattaching it to the roots it's not
going to happen I think you can slice it
back on okay come on okay I'm talking
about a political metaphor
uh
for sure no I mean
to Perhaps Perhaps there is a way to
reconnect with our roots and that's
actually a good way to put it so I
actually uh I stand corrected if we can
restore Our Roots and get back to what
made this country function better maybe
we can turn things around I think
there's a good opportunity for that but
right now what I see around us
well actually you know maybe you were
completely right what I see around us is
is a light at the end of the tunnel with
the with the Republicans taking the
house this may be the point where we
start turning things around if more
shows like this more more people like
Crowder more people like stick sex and
Hammer more shows pushing through the
noise more people able to counter The
Narrative Elon Musk taking over Twitter
that was great this is this is a
potential opportunity to start rejecting
societal collapse and degeneracy and
saying there's got to be some degree of
responsibility
meritocracy uh protecting the family
maybe maybe we actually are restoring
those things
I was thinking I like this metaphor
about when was the when was the flower
cut was it the Federal Reserve Act 1913
Woodrow Wilson did he slice no was it
the 90s because Reagan was awesome I
remember Reagan was pulling down the
Berlin wall and like ending the Cold War
it's it's the 2000s and I think it was
social media that was the internet yeah
the internet algorithms algorithmic
manipulation uh and the financial
collapse these things all happened right
around the same time but didn't you guys
feel that we got a little reprieve when
Trump won like I thought the country was
going it was so horrible 2016's the
first time I voted you know I just
couldn't I had to get involved and vote
the way the country was going like it
was now it's just no like no different
from when Obama ran things from when
Biden's running things there's two ways
so I thought that you know him getting
elected I thought you know patriotism
look there's no patriotism now in this
country he brought back patriotism and
the country was definitely doing a lot
better then than it is now there's two
ways to look at I guess uh I've heard
these stories about old people on their
deathbed you know they're lethargic
they're dying and then one day all of a
sudden they sit up
tons of energy they're talking They're
laughing they say get my family in here
I'm feeling great and they're like whoa
the family comes in they all share
laughs and memories and then say goodbye
and the next day the person dies like
all of their energy is mustered up for
one last goodbye and I love you that
scares me that idea that the Resurgence
of trump was the last mustering force of
people who care about this country and
believe in the values that made it great
you believe that no I think it's a
possibility but it's also possible that
Donald Trump was a shot of adrenaline
that he was that EpiPen straightened to
the thigh and now where's the country
went
so as we have these bad things still
happening around us we now have the rise
of people like DeSantis we now have the
narrative machine crumbling we now have
Elon buying Twitter far from perfect
this guy Elon but he's releasing these
documents he did more for the for social
media than any GOP the GOP evidence
did to beat the big Tech just recently
private sector yep yeah but but maybe
Donald Trump was we were all sitting
around feeling our heart tighten and
then Trump came along like an EpiPen for
all his faults he was he was a shot of
adrenaline and now the vision's very
clear and all this transparent nonsense
you're like what like the FBI is
directly involved with it I mean we kind
of have the feeling this was going on
screaming it from the top of his lungs
about it for years you know the FBI the
Department of Justice the collusion the
Russian BS you know and it was all it
all came out to be true let's let's talk
about some uh uh what's what's going on
here because this is this is a dark
subject I want to bring up we got Mike
cernovich here
he says ask anyone inside a large
organization who is really in control
the answer is always HR Twitter's trust
and safety was HR on liver King levels
of steroids you crossed them and you're
out for being dangerous and a threat he
said that in response to this tweet from
Daniel Bostic who says uh either uh he
says cernovich just exposed a divide
between Elon and Jack either Jack was
lying all along and is carrying on the
deception not super likely or his
company was totally hijacked by far left
activists and Lawless corporate
bureaucrats very likely let's get into
it
Mike cernovich responded to a tweet from
Twitter's trust and safety saying they
were resigning he said you all belong in
jail and linked to a story from the New
York Post Twitter refused to remove
child porn because it didn't violate
their rules Elon Musk says it is a crime
that they refuse to take action on child
exploitation for years Jack Dorsey said
this is false Elon Musk responded no it
is not when Ella Irwin who now runs
trust and safety joins Twitter earlier
this year almost no one was working on
child safety she raised this with Ned
and parag but they rejected her Staffing
request I made it top priority
immediately
this is the level of corruption we have
seen in this country on Twitter for
years on social media they were posting
pictures of children in disgusting ways
and they did nothing so when we say that
Elon Musk did more than the GOP ever did
more than the FBI ever did he gets in
day one he says my top priority ending
child exploitation
it gets even worse than that there was
victims of a lot of this
CP a lot of this adult child content
that were coming to Twitter and were
saying hey uh this has happened to me of
being targeted my photos here are being
released here I was a child this is
illegal please get rid of it Twitter was
like hmm too bad we're going after uh
all the Republicans we're going after
we're gonna ban Laura oh yeah we're
gonna ban the people for their political
speech and and that right there shows
you uh the priority that they had there
as of course I was screaming about this
years ago I was like there's there's
Isis on the platform there's people
beheading people there's there's radical
islamist recruiting on the platform and
your main priority is a satire uh
comedian are you freaking kidding me you
have so much to do and you fail us time
and time again so the Ayatollah of Iran
saying death to Israel death to America
and nothing happened with his Twitter
Chinese propaganda Chinese government
actors coming on nope nope that's fine
yeah so seeing Jack come out and then
being smacked down by Elon Musk is uh
absolutely promising because what Elon
Musk is talking about here is Criminal
if you know a crime is going on and you
don't do anything about it you're a part
of that act a lot of people get charged
for this for for being an accomplice uh
there was children coming to Twitter and
they ignored them well is absolutely
just just that should let's boil your
blood right now let's contextualize this
it's not like you know what what was the
last episode of Seinfeld they the Good
Samaritan law they get arrested it
wasn't like someone was standing on the
side of the road they saw someone
getting kidnapped and went I'm not
getting involved no no no this was
they're driving the car and they they
get an Uber and they pick someone up
who's like grabbing a woman off the
street and throwing them in the car and
like hey man I'm just a driver don't
mind me
that's what it was Twitter was
facilitating this Twitter had created a
platform allowing these people to do
these things to post these things they
were the vehicle by which this stuff was
delivered and they had an obligation to
say we can't have that illegal activity
in our bus so that they did nothing it's
not just Twitter it's every song of
course of course because they're smart
man give it you got to give it to them
they control all the social media they
won these elections uh and they control
the universities like before you were
saying they control education uh the
Democrats you got to put you gotta tell
them you know they did something right
all the social media mainstream media
education they control everything and
and everyone in society so if we don't
do anything about it now like Tim says
we're going down a terrible path we
built mines The Social Network and I was
an administrator for like five years and
we had to deal with this fortunately it
was a smaller amount of people per day
probably one percent of what Twitter
gets so it was still manageable
centrally we still had centralized
administratorship which is a fault of a
system you can't a centralized planned
system cannot handle that amount of
child porn that will come on but you'd
send it immediately the FBI if you find
something illegal particularly something
as you reach out to child porn FBI
immediately is notified and that is it's
removed you can't even have it there in
a holding pattern because having it is
illegal so you need to immediately
reference and take it yeah it was on
Twitter servers as Twitter was meeting
with the FBI as they were ignoring the
problem you never saw the feds
investigate Twitter for this but now
they're investigating him because Elon
Musk took the company over and is
prioritizing going after child
pornography on on the damn program on on
the damn platform are you kidding me I
understand
who Clinton hired to when she cleaned
all the rematch how did they not know
you know what I mean he's going to come
in and go through everything and expose
them all like how did they not bleach at
all I could see the argument of like is
just too much data like there's no way
we can handle this but that's like I
agree so maybe you shouldn't be in
control of it if you can't handle it
um that's not the argument they
knowingly knew it was happening they
knew the victims and they said we're
just going to keep it up what Jack said
when they said uh Twitter did nothing to
prevent this Jack said this is not true
I think what Jack it's kind of like
double speak what he's saying is no we
did some things to try and prevent it
but what elon's saying is it wasn't
prevented you may have that wasn't their
top priority the priority was to censor
conservatives right that's what they
were getting at somebody posted a Super
Chat Murph tries I want to read this one
he says Elon we are going after CP
celebrities quote this platform just
isn't what it used to be I'm leaving you
think about that and you think it's a
joke right but then you think about
people like you know Harvey over in
Hollywood and what he was into and then
I you know I'm thinking about this these
Twitter employees who refuse to quit but
then Elon comes and starts cleaning
stuff up and then all of a sudden
they're like oh no no no now I have to
leave and then you take a look at books
like that genderqueer where it's got
adult activities in it and they're
showing it to kids and uh you have the
school in Chicago that project Veritas
exposes where the dean talks about how
he brings people in to share adult toys
with children and explain how to insert
them and the difference between lube and
spit and you have to wonder are we just
being naive in assuming these people
don't want to Target and Prey Upon
children yes because there's also the
Balenciaga Scandal there's also the
corporate media advocating for for child
love there's also of course politicians
trying to normalize a lot of this
nonsense and Insanity especially in
California there's also the FBI for over
30 years that were helping Jeffrey
Epstein run an international trafficking
and extortion operation as the children
and victims were coming forward to the
FBI and the FBI said screw off so this
is not a coincidence I don't think this
is an act on top of that is Sam bankman
freed no child porn involved in the
sandbag and free thing but he had like
sleeping with like eight or nine
different women that he was working with
that's not the same thing but it's a
highly sexual no no no no no there's a
better place point in their Ian and it's
that they're not going after him they
haven't talked about the section I mean
not that there's anything wrong with
sleeping with nine different women that
work for you I don't care but uh you
could argue about the ethics involved in
that but the the where's the where's the
talk about it like it's so underground
sexual you know but it's not I don't I
don't care about the SPF orgy stuff I
care about the SPF illegality that
they're not going after why because he
aligned with them politically there's
also there's also cuties on Netflix
there's so many examples of this just to
go back on this particular topic related
to this larger discussion that Elon Musk
is talking about I mean how more blatant
do you need it to get what what do you
need politicians ditching their secret
service and going to private islands oh
wait hold on yeah how more obvious do
you need to to make it seriously yeah
what happened with uh Menendez remember
that one yeah uh what happened with
Trump's uh what was it Transportation
secretary uh who gave him the sweetheart
deal of a lifetime you know again we can
keep going
my problem with repealing Section 230
protections for these social networks is
that someone in the FBI could put child
porn on the Twitter server and then go
arrest the CEO for holding child porn
you're like that's what and you can try
and track it but they're so good at
hiding where it came from that's not
section 230 pertains to civil litigation
civil tort I hope so but I mean I think
you really do need to protect these
these platforms as egregious as it seems
It's hard to navigate under that premise
Ian you're saying that section 230
actually allows someone to legally hold
child exploitative material it doesn't
these platforms like you were saying you
can't have it section 230 does not
protect that
okay yeah yeah this is a it's a it's a
long-term conversation about things
other than child porn as well but things
that may be deemed illegal and about
who's in trouble for having the illegal
confidence
sheriff in Florida like everybody knows
him his name is Grady Judd he's like
pretty famous and they're constantly
setting up this child this child
pornography Rings you know always online
you always read about them they're
arresting so they should be doing more
stuff like that but counties could do
that you know you don't have to leave it
to the the main social media platform if
it's happening in your county then they
can set these people up and hold them
accountable where they should be I think
it was crazy the last time he made an
arrest in Polk County uh a lot of these
people were working at Disney you know
they did a sting operation oh yeah you
remember that Grady Judd did uh Sheriff
Grady he did a sting operation and hit
and like I don't know like 10 people
were working at Disney imagine that you
know you have your kid you're strolling
around and you got one of those Mickey
Mouse kids and that routinely happens
there's a lot of news stories month
after month caught at Disney caught at
Disney Disney employee or Disney Network
again again they play a lot of people
but there's also a lot of coincidences
especially with some of their uh
symbolism and some of their child movies
that is also very disturbing and
deserves a conversation on its own so
these people get a job at Disney it's
obvious right they want to talk at kids
what other place do you think these
people might try and find employment
where they can surround themselves with
children is there is another another job
like you know public service inside of
Nursery Square this where the kids go
you know what what I'm I'm trying to
elude yeah yeah yeah yeah oh that's an
interesting point oh that's right if
they're going to go to Disneyland or
world or whatever because a lot of kids
there maybe many of these people go to
grade schools too to be surrounded by
kids there as well
oh I I well I could talk about the
school sexualization but I mean you made
a good point about the entertainment
industry you said you guys mentioned
Disney but that whole industry man it is
dirty for kids it is dangerous to get
kids into that I was there as an adult
and they were trying to sexually get me
to do porn scary you can't yeah raising
a kid these days you just can't you guys
have any of you have kids no negative
I wouldn't be telling anybody uh one day
all right guys they'll have kids and
you'll see you know you just gonna have
to keep an eye on them and private
school is the answer
the world is so crazy if I would have a
kid I would never be posting photos of
it I would never tell anybody about it
because how vicious and crazy some
people are small you know yep a lot of
people will I worry all the time what my
sons you know every day I worry where
they are that's everyone and they're
adults you know just because I'm damaged
from what I went through I can't you
couldn't imagine something that happened
at The Wanted of them I would see
pictures of people with their newborn
babies but they'll put like a block the
face out a lot of people in the last 15
years were putting the full baby face
and everything online so everyone knows
what their kid looks like beautiful baby
it's a chance for us to be like Yay
let's support the beauty of the child
and I think it Collective Consciousness
I think that it actually enhances the
beauty of humans when we can all
appreciate each other but
it also lets everyone in the world know
what your baby looks like and that's
like you were saying Luke I mean that's
that's pretty pretty wickedly terrifying
you know because I we know that
governments will go after people's kids
they'll be like you should have had a
better father there was a uh Jamal
what's his name this is khashoggi is the
guy that he was the reporter that he was
the show he's a different guy it was the
kid the 16 year old was killed by Obama
on a drone oh Abdul Rahman
and is the son of a terrorist you know
what they call the terrorists
he was working with the Pentagon before
when it came to de-radicalization so he
was working with also the Intel
intelligence agency the father yes yeah
okay so yeah yeah Anwar I don't think uh
his dad committed any crimes he was a
preacher he preached to Jihad against
America I see and they said well his
speeches you know weren't I could be
wrong about that but let's just that
that's why I usually I stick to
discussing abdulrahman 16 year old kid
from Boulder lived in San Diego goes our
uh I think that's what it was then he
goes and flies to Yemen to visit family
and then Obama blows him up well the
father had a lot of connections to the
government and the Pentagon and then he
became radicalized and became a cleric
and then started preaching uh you know
radical Islam and then the son was
killed yeah he was killed the sun was
killed and then the and then there's
reports of the daughter being killed uh
off of uh the first uh you know First
Command of the Trump Administration on a
Commando raid that Obama wouldn't uh
call off on but Trump allegedly called
off on that's the official version of
events it could have been an accident
could have been North Korea style family
targeted execution I don't claim to know
what's going on no I think I think the
United States sent a clear message that
if you screw with us we kill your kids I
thought so too yeah I mean that's Vibe
I'm getting and partly why I don't want
to put pictures of my kids all over the
internet I mean if you look at the
extradition and torture that the
intelligence agencies were doing
especially when it came to flying people
to Egypt
um what's his name talks about this
oh imagine the ones really talks about
this all the time sorry for butchering
your name I think I'm just dyslexic and
I'm just horrible with pronouncing names
but he talks about how you know many
times routinely people get picked up
sent to Egypt and again we can't even
discuss some of the horrible things the
torture that people gone through
officially under the rendition flights
and the torture flights that were
conducted with your tax dollars and
including children including hurting
children in front of parents and doing
unspeakable things that you can't even
mention uh uh how do you say his name
again oh it's magic like magic yeah
magic talks about this in in detail but
it's but it's a conversation that a lot
of people aren't ready for you'll always
remember Magic's name because it's like
magic
grew up with a kid in High School's last
name was magic dude magic Nawaz is a
brilliant uh I don't know what you call
him a scholar I don't know how you
define the guy I formed terrorists I
believe yeah yeah he's a brilliant guy
he was in that prison in Egypt he
describes his his you know situation
um he's he's a brilliant uh fascinating
thinker and his content is Top Notch
right now when it comes to speaking out
against a lot of the craziness that
Society is is dealing with and now he's
helping de-radicalize a lot of people uh
which I think is absolutely critically
key and important and in many instances
doing the opposite of what the Intel
agencies are doing I think a lot of the
benefit people could get right now is is
don't worry so much about showing the
world your life I kind of went through a
phase where I was like I want to
document everything so everyone I can
get my likes and then and also I'll be
remembered you know who doesn't want to
be remembered but it can be like less is
more sometimes I think you guys get a
good uh what you're doing you move to
rural areas I think it's great I live
all right chickens goats chicken cam you
got to do a goat cam at my place yeah
goat City we could do a goat Camp so
living rural I think is going to be the
future for a lot of families doing some
homesteading raising your own beef being
that's a way to get your family uh be
involved with them and Robin eggs fresh
air no pollution people go tap their
sink water in the city and then they
they're like I gotta go to the grocery
store to buy my food you think it's your
food you think that's your water they
can turn it off if the grocery store
doesn't have it you don't happen you saw
it with covet you couldn't get you
couldn't get a lot of the things where I
live you know I'm hungry I'll just go
out and kill a goat or you know what I
mean we got no more chickens the dog ate
all my chicken but I have like you know
120 goats they're great to watch they
have two to three a year you know so
they're constantly growing I don't name
any of them they're all numbered yeah
Ranch you never name anything I I heard
something really clever from uh I think
it was from Kim she's our chicken tender
she said uh a friend names their Birds
after holidays so that one's Christmas
you know that's good that one's
Thanksgiving and then you know when you
eat them yeah that's pretty cool but we
don't the only thing that has names on
my Ranch is dogs how many dogs we have
three dogs two livestock Guardian dogs
and I have a Malinois which one is the
the Anatolian [ __ ] but I couldn't knock
that out I have a German Shepherd too I
raised it on a farm and I and I made
sure to teach it I was like hey you stay
away from the chickens you respect the
chickens yeah it was tough it was
because they have that drive especially
the Shepherds they love to taste things
around they love that thing running
around they're like we need to get it it
was it was a lot of fun I have a
Malinois that's trained to a tea like I
love them I got him when he was two
months old and he was like I training
him to not go after the chickens but
e-collar is a really good tool for
anyone that that's training the dog
seriously I have an e-collar and he it
didn't take me too long for him to keep
him off the chickens but what's pretty
interesting now is you know he's a
protection dog and he does everything
for me but now I got him hurting Tilly
he loves it man I'll go out like you
know there'll be a hundred goats out
there and he can move them you know I
got to be really quick with the button
because he says Drive will get too hard
and he could easily like just break
one's neck how much how much so how much
land do you need for a hundred goats
well I have about 750 Acres wow and we
move him it's pretty I live in this area
that uh it's it's free open range So
lately the price of hay went from like
seven dollars a bale to now 21 a bill so
a lot of times I just opened my Gates
and I just say you know this is
nothing's for free here you know what I
mean it's not like in the City where you
get your food stamps and you don't have
to go work for yourself so I send the
goats like hey go out there get find
something to eat or you're not going to
get you're not going to have anything
you're going to go hungry so it's pretty
interesting I wake up in the morning I'm
looking out my Ranch I see him going out
the front my front the gate they're
going down the street like a mile and
then I'm telling you it's unbelievable
they come back the end of the day
they're coming back back they know where
it's safe and they're such interesting
animals to watch I went to California
during the drought to interview farmers
and we went to a bunch of dairy farms I
go to one and we just we literally just
walked up to houses knocked on doors and
you know guy answers and we were like
Hey we're reporters we're uh we wanted
to get the opinion of farmers because of
the drought because of the regulations
and he's like yeah for sure and he walks
out and he he shows us around the edge
on the side of his building and there's
a whole bunch of cows just eaten and
there's no fencing or anything they had
their their machine where the cows could
go and get milked they had the thing
where all the food was being put and uh
I can't remember exactly it was probably
hay or something and I don't know what
they were eating but then I was like
there's there's no fences and he's like
yeah and I was like can they just leave
and he goes where would they go and I
was like I don't know just like randomly
walking off and going somewhere and he
was like
but where like why would they leave
their house yeah they're not going
anywhere he's like I don't need to put a
fence up I'm not worried about it it's
like there's no Predators that's like
the kid that doesn't leave his house
living in the basement he's got the
refrigerator's full it's got heat air
conditioning he's got cars now anyway
yeah the cow's got it made they don't
want to leave yeah these goats I thought
when I first got them they were like I
thought they would never come back and
it's just interesting they cut they're
creatures and they they are so they're
coming back so how one how much is how
much is like the average goat weigh
average goat I would say is about the
the mama goats probably about 130 140
pounds so how long how much food does
one goat produce oh the food probably
about 40 pounds 40 pounds or 40 pounds
of meat uh for each goat it's delicious
like I don't want a bite like I'm I'm at
the point now I got I just started to
herd of cattle too so we have about five
uh you learn a lot about the cow
business you know when living on a ranch
what a heifer is what a cow what a bull
heifer is there's just so many cows that
you know they'll teach you something so
if a cow's pregnant you don't say
pregnant's covered or open if they're
not pregnant they're open if they're
pregnant they're covered this is what I
learned from East Coast out to Oregon
how long does that 40 pound of meat last
you got your family
uh last well we usually like I'm pretty
generous with it you know all the time
with friends and family we're always
like we gave it away or we're always
constantly eating it you know but we uh
it's really great to be able to raise
your own meat I explain it to people
it's like what's the difference between
having a garden and raising Tomatoes I'm
just raising beef right well goat you
know what you know right there that's
what life I love it man I I using the
stuff that you raise and I know what
they're eating I have no problem killing
them what about the Udders and like the
internal organs do you eat that stuff
too no no no beef liver
we gotta have a conversation about it as
a kid I used to eat liver all the time
when I was growing up but I haven't I
have my first steer now so he's about uh
700 about 600 pounds so I won't butcher
him till the fall he was born in June
but I have another five that are covered
that'll be given birth and they they
take about nine months you know to give
birth Earth the cow and a goats about
five months if you're not going to be
doing anything with the liver I'll
gladly take it off of your hands but but
I would love to have a conversation
about organ meat because there's there's
a lot of important stuff that a lot of
people don't um get especially when it
comes to a lot of the American diets
comparatively to a lot of other
International diets that do prioritize
organs because they're usually more
nutrient dense than of course makes
sense but I'm definitely not going to
let anything go to yeah you know loss
people the saying is usually nose to
tail you know the butcher's so it's
crazy they're so busy like where we live
that you could make an appointment like
if you want to butcher a cow it could be
like seven eight months out whoa for the
butcher to come so I'm almost half to
like for the next fall soon I'll have to
make unless my neighbor I got a neighbor
that's a pretty good butcher there's a
huge shortage and it's so expensive many
people don't understand that's one of
the biggest expensive uh you know Parts
when it comes to racing it costs me if I
want one of my neighbors he'll do a goat
for me for about a hundred the the you
know you're raising these animals do you
have concerns about parasites in them
when you're eating them hey no we
constantly you know that uh you know not
all the time if I see I know now from
watching when an animal's sick and we'll
treat it and once a year I'll treat them
and everybody in the herd of ivamectin
so ivomechten works great uh for the
power sites uh with goats you know you
just put a syringe you just fill it and
you they need it you know is that all
you use I remember them yeah and well
you know with the goats is I'm fortunate
I have a lot of pasture and irrigation
so I can move them around it's when
these animals sit in like their own
pasture and they'll eat stuff down and
they get sick a lot more because they're
eating down to the ground where their
feces are yeah so I learned all you know
I went from looking at scrap metal to
looking at real estate now I look at
Goat [ __ ] on my Ranch to see if they're
sick so it's crazy you do have cows
though right yeah we have some cows how
much milk uh per day does it come oh we
don't we use a beef cows there's beef
cows there's Angus there's herefords
there's Charlize you know you'll learn
all these things oh yeah yeah we want to
get a cow and we were told no because
they produce like eight to twelve
gallons per day what what they're not
telling you is like even with the goats
like if you stop milking a goat it's
like a full-time job if they don't have
a kid on them you got a milk like twice
a day or they go through like some
serious pain yeah but I don't you're
gonna get get a beef cow you buy a steer
and you got enough Akins you put a steer
on it and you feed them or you probably
have enough feed on what you what you
said you had how many acres you got
black 50. so you got a lot of trees
though oh yeah but I don't know they'll
be able to fall I didn't want it
everything right they eat the
blackberries you gotta see I'm like in
Blackberry
they just that's their favorite food the
blackberries and they and blackberries
grow like four feet a year if I didn't
have these goats eating I would be it
would be unbelievable the what they do
to keep my place looking nice how often
you move them like from do you do
Paddock to panic that's usually you
don't want them in the of course the
parasites have a cycle so you don't
really want them in there more than a
month and area and I'll move them to
another pasture right now I went there
with not a lot of stuff I've been
letting them go up the mountain and they
got they're on their own are they smart
enough where if it's like poop grass and
not poop grass they'll eat the non-poop
grass poop grass oh they usually they go
find the best stuff like they won't eat
like the stuff you want them to eat they
don't eat it like you know the stuff
that's growing where it's like at they
go to the good stuff you know like in
life it's like a kid it opens the
refrigerator he's gonna grab go for the
ice cream before he goes for the
vegetables to go to the same way they go
for the they go for the sweet stuff
unless you lock them you lock them in
there then you force them to eat it with
like electric fence yeah then they'll
then they'll eat my mom did that to me
one night when I wouldn't finish no
electric fence involved but it was a
similar we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
to support our work directly when you do
you are using the financial system
parallel economy co-founded by Dan Dan
bongino so we're trying to get away from
PayPal and these other companies we're
trying to build a parallel economy and
that's why we have secured a new
location for a physical Enterprise where
we want to do the Saturday morning
cartoons we want to have a game shop a
skate shop we're going to have a whole
bunch of good fun stuff happening we
have this little Nook area we're going
to call Ian's Crystal Cove or something
like that nice I'm excited I'm gonna put
up a curtain and we're going to put a
sofa and like lava lamps and like a TV
for movies how about a couple of goats
well we can't put them in the cities you
can't you can't put a couple of goats in
there no it's uh they have that goat
yoga now on everything Urban yeah that's
fun but uh there's a there's a it's the
way it's shaped there's this little Nook
area where I think we can put up like
curtains and then you'll walk in with
your coffee and sit down and there'll be
like a TV with a movie playing and you
know rocks everywhere it'll be good fun
so let's uh let's read those super chats
all right gemcast says Tim this is my
last five bucks please pull up Title 18
USC section 241 Twitter directly
violated it
well there you go give me that again
Title 18 USC section 241.
all right I prefer Rumble says Tim in
response to your 90s commercial today
about Taco Bell their slogan was Run for
the Border not sure how well that would
go over today LOL
yeah it's funny too they uh I heard that
they tried to open Taco Bell in Mexico
as American food but nobody wanted to
eat it yeah
we used to joke about that make a run
for the border and then be like make a
run for the toilet is what the joke was
that's right I stopped using the we have
in Oregon you have the best food Mexican
food trucks that you could ever oh man
it's unbelievable that's food it's
better than any restaurant you go to the
food trucks they're the best L.A did you
find the the the law yeah conspiracy
against rights it's a U.S federal crime
really what does it say conspiracy
against rights is a federal offense in
the United States of America under 18
USC 241 if two or more persons conspire
to injure or press threaten or
intimidate any person in the free
exercise of enjoyment of any right or
privilege secured to him by the
Constitution it goes on wow yeah it's
pretty pretty broad so we need the FBI
to investigate itself conspiracy against
rights good luck with that right exactly
that would be the law
Raymond g Stanley Jr says the year is
2029. Liberty was so 1990s ago for
damastan the Hub of culture news
politics is kept safe by armed patrols
drones historians will link the shift in
tactics by Tim Poole back to this week
yeah maybe I guess I don't know
part of me wants to say start moving two
cities you know move into the urban
centers and then vote against all these
people but I could not advocate for that
you know get out take care of yourself
get some goats get some chickens I like
the starting new city ever you ever
think about starting a new city like
Astor John Astor did in New York and I
don't know I like keeping people away
from me it's better I got goats and
cattle and dogs you know well we'll do
it we'll uh you know what I mean but you
could there are people it's a you know
there's people moving you know that
that's what's going on now people are
moving to the states that are more
like-minded like they are and that you
could see it's like steps you know
people move when they move to Florida
they're moving to Tennessee like
everyone you talk to every retired cops
moving to Tennessee you know that that's
really what's going on we'll do it I'm
in what we'll do is we'll buy acreage in
West Virginia we'll set up a designated
space as the downtown and then what you
do is you basically lease or sell small
plots like half acre plots to people who
want to set up businesses and then we
create a market store trip that people
can go and hang out and you know I
already have the land you could bring
them bring it out to me in Florida
awesome Oregon oh in Oregon there you go
just can't bring any Democrats out yeah
well conservative people we could find a
spot for them all right let's grab some
more where we at
Tori bretlian says so we release a
well-known International arms dealer
while Russia is fighting Ukraine after
we left billions in weapons in
Afghanistan while we also can't find uh
can't find all of the Ukraine Aid
interesting
uh-huh that's right as Biden is calling
for gun control as he just released uh
what is known to be one of the most
dangerous dealers in the world he's
worried about that The Merchant of death
all right let's see
um the real Hydro PX says the evidence
that Luke and Tim are the best hosts
ever I'm such a big fan of this show I
Super Chat all the time you guys are the
greatest Tim I think you're my favorite
journalist and Luke you have to be one
of the most handsome people ever Hydro
how could you say such nice things about
us I'm kidding hydra's always got the
comments here he says the evidence that
Luke and Tim are the and most of these
so-called journalists are conformist
they will never be mentioned on Twitter
files sure thing buddy but I do
appreciate the super chats we do we do
appreciate that you're voicing your
criticisms and uh you know I really I'm
glad you know not everybody's here just
to to say nice things you had me in the
first quarter
in the first one yeah I wonder if
hydro's like I didn't say that he's fake
news waffle Sensei says I am very happy
to see Twitter gaining traffic for the
story coming out there but coming out on
a Friday on Twitter is killing the story
and giving the press the ability to
avoid it
I think the reason they're doing it I
think uh Elon told them it has to be
released you know on Twitter at this
these times because these are probably
low traffic times for Twitter
the weekend look it's Friday night I
think we had like 33 000 people watch we
normally do you know 40 45 but that's
Friday you know who wants to be indoors
listening to commentary on news and
stuff and politics it's Christmas is
coming up it's time to get out go have a
good night enjoy yourself and forget
about all the bad stuff so uh viewership
is lower on the weekends I think that
was it like do this so that people come
and get on Twitter on the weekends I
just looked and saw that Eliza blue did
a conversation with Elon six hours ago
or so Eliza is known for being an
advocate against child pornography or
exploitation she herself was a victim
um and I don't know if is that the right
phrasing Eliza sorry if I miss miss
phrasing things that you've gone through
but I'm so glad to see that Eliza and
Elon have gotten together it's uh on
Twitter now right on that's interesting
Ian Bridget says Tim you should get your
own investigation going on who is
swatting you hire someone private
investigators some kind of black hat
hacker get some answers
we have answers
the issue is only law enforcement can
actually act upon those answers and
they're not
what is swatting it's when someone calls
uh 911 oh I heard about that and that
that happened to you 15 times this year
yeah bomb squads come out twice
maybe even three times third time
after the first time well Marjorie
Taylor they keep coming up Marjorie no
no no no no see people don't understand
they think of swatting is like every
single time the swatcom SWAT team barges
in no no after the first time they show
up in a patrol car
everything good all right have a nice
day guys but we have private security so
now what happens is they just relay with
our with our armed guards and so you
know I think the running comes in they
make a phone call they say we're all
good okay they're gonna come by and do a
checkup and then everything's fine it
probably came from like the earlier days
of the internet when people would call
in like uh there's a violent thing and
then the SWAT team would go bust in the
door right yeah on the ground on the
ground someone's like what the hell is
happening yep but I mean people get
killed people have been killed this
happened to you 15 times yeah I think
15. um here in this facility and then
also at some other locations like my
private home was targeted so we have we
have uh uh we have information that I
believe would lead to the arrest of
individuals involved but law enforcement
is the FBI just doesn't care like that's
why that that's one maybe it's my bias
because seeing that happen but but I
think a better thing is you know take it
off myself Marjory Taylor green gets
swatted six times I think was it six
you'd think the FBI would be stopping
that no they only operate to protect
their political ideological so that
should make you feel not bad if they're
not helping her right well it makes me
it makes me feel like this country
doesn't exist yeah it's terrible it
would just you look at the not look into
it in California they're releasing
criminals while crime is skyrocketing
and shutting down prisons there is no
functioning executive uh you know Oregon
you can walk around with two grams of
coke or meth and not get arrested I did
I do work with law enforcement so I did
recently I did a drive a drive around
with one of the sergeants and he said
you could pick these guys up with two
grams of coke or meth or mushrooms and
there's nothing that happened no arrests
not even a ticket or nothing nothing
they don't even bother that they don't
even have now you know I'm into the I
have a Malinois so I train with a lot of
canine units they don't even get dogs
that are drug dogs anymore only
apprehension because they don't even
care about the drugs it's just because
they just have more on their hands to
deal with more violence I guess they're
they're just taking that approach you
know they're just not going to arrest
they're not going to put them through
the system this is just horrible you see
the homeless like the homeless
populations like California Oregon's the
same I did a ride along in Miami
um first thing within the few minutes a
high speed chase oh wow that's crazy it
was insane this is I I went to night
crawling in Chicago
man I you you that's not for the faint
of heart in nightcrawling you guys know
what that is journalists go out at like
10 p.m and they get the radio they get
the police scanner and they drive around
and then they speed they get this as
fast as they can to the crime scenes to
film and document then sell it to the
local news agencies I think we saw what
five murders in the span of a couple
hours there was one where uh there was a
house and it's Chicago so it's not like
everyone's a homeowner the top floor was
where the guys lived the bottom floor
was like the land the house homeowner
renting at the top floor and the guys up
top owed money to somebody or or I I
don't I can't remember exactly what
happened the car pulls up just unloads
into the house kills like I think killed
the woman or something I can't remember
exactly this gun laws in the country how
many murders are taking place every
weekend how many Iraq and killed right
this is this is an important Super Chat
here slain hope with a really really
good point he says the death penalty is
tricky because of Vegeta from Dragon
Ball had Goku not spared him trunks
would have never been born and Earth
would be lost well that prison I mean
right there that's just you know death
penalty out the door yeah completely
esoteric over everyone's head except for
those that are big Dragon Ball Z fans
all right th says just heard scnr
subverse settled what next Tim
uh you may have seen that the there was
a lawsuit subverse settled there is
information available on the wefinder
website and uh the only thing that I can
say is that I can't say anything just
yet so a lot of people are saying like
we want answers what's going on why
aren't we getting answers
legal restrictions like it's it's
basically how uh these things work but
uh we probably have a bunch of updates
uh
soon maybe and what you can do is you
can read all the files from the lawsuit
as well as a decision that was issued by
the California Department of industrial
relations to get an understanding of of
what happened and I will leave it at
that and then hopefully uh as we
continue to work on this we'll have more
for you soon
all right where are we at
we'll grab some more Super chats
oh let's see
Skyler says Utah any staff or parent
with a concealed carry on campus why
doesn't uh Utah have school shootings I
don't know maybe it's because even Utah
employment law protects ccw's at schools
I would also argue with how religious
Utah is you know you're going to get
less of those mental health problems and
the less hopelessness that a lot of
these kids are facing these days
all right let's see
Miss Martin music says how Meadow died
is a must read for anyone even thinking
of having children in any school as a
teacher I can say that it is an accurate
portrayal of who is at school with your
kids
thank you you wrote did you write it
yeah I wrote it and every parent should
read it that wants to send their child
into a public school it's very
educational it's all the facts what I
uncovered in the shooting all the
failures I put it into this book it's
like a handbook for parents you know
because the media
they focus on gun control that's what
happened that's all those kids everyone
knows those kids got so much media
attention but when it came time to get
anything done
the cameras left and so today they left
and they didn't do crap you know we we
got so much I told you about the
accountability we got done in Florida we
got a bill passed that made it a law for
every school in the state of Florida to
have a deputy one for every 500.
that's something that we got done after
the shooting a single point of entries
at every school
teachers are allowed you know the Aaron
Feist Guardian program so a lot of
things got done in Florida after the
shooting that the media doesn't want to
cover because their main focus is just
more gun control
right on
EF says Mr Pollock I am sorry for you
and your family it sounds like your
daughter was a was heroic woman trying
to protect others thank you for working
to protect other kids is there any way
we can help you
oh they could just follow me at on my
Twitter Andrew Pollock FL uh I do a lot
of fundraising on my own well with some
corporations I I hate it's the worst
thing in the world to ask people for
money I hate doing it in campaigns I
just I don't like doing it asking people
for funds but I do what I have to do and
I'm helping law enforcement agencies
I'll be in pull I'll be in Bradford
County Florida January 4th with their
Sheriff's Department donating uh AR
pistols with Ballistic backpacks for
their school resource officers and their
school superintendent it'll be the first
superintendent to carry an AR pistol in
the country wow right on it's really
cool can people help support financially
I I don't really push for it but I guess
I could put a link sometimes yeah I
don't even have a link where they could
donate but you know I'm with this
company it's called burna.com and uh
people should we got some of those yeah
I gotta get I'm going to get you some
more is that what you were talking about
earlier yeah yeah you guys were
mentioning it we have we have a couple
of those they're the we have uh they're
they're basically like uh uh paintball
plus a serious one right like they have
like a tear gas pellet uh anyone out
there that has a student uh in college
or anywhere they have a bad guy
repellent so I I was fortunate enough to
be able to work with this company I'm
the chief Public Safety Officer and
through sales they donate money to my
Foundation wow and then where I'm able
to use that money and donate like the
rifles and backpacks to Lauren we got we
got a bunch of those we got a bunch of
the you know the downstairs okay you'll
show me and I'll like to get you some
more stuff they also have a product
that's called The Shield that I think
parents could get for around a hundred
dollars and it could go in a backpack uh
or a suitcase and it makes it uh
bulletproof one of the things that we uh
wanted to do was to build a couple Auto
defense turrets that shoot the the burn
uh projectiles so there's we have a
couple there's the there's the tear gas
one it's it they don't call tear gas
it's called something else right Max Pro
I think it's the max well the Max Pro is
a combination isn't it isn't it like the
max Pros the tear gas and then they have
a pepper ball pepper ball and they
they're just extremely powerful you know
my son was talking about something like
that like how they have like automatic
lights that go on in the corner your
house you could have that like a
launcher set up at your house that'll
automatically shoot well if it picks up
something on a big property there's no
reason for someone to be anywhere near
certain areas and so my plan was to
create maybe seven Auto defense turrets
each holding about a thousand of the the
burner rounds in them and uh non-lethal
of course so when something comes with
proximity to the animals be it a wild
animal or a trespasser of some sort you
get lights turn on then a warning and
then it goes yeah but they they have
ones that I've seen with law enforcement
that are for crowd control that you fill
with like a bucket yeah of the pellets
like if you had them like on a terror it
would be on believable if they got to
that where it could do the software for
that would be pretty amazing now what I
want to do is we just have a switch so
at the end of the day when you're going
inside and locking up you flick a switch
and then four you know maybe like six
around your house or just slowly like
looking and then they lock on and it's
like you are being warned that's Auto
defense with the car alarms you know
staying back so there's no reason that
that technology isn't going to be here
shortly I wonder about the legalities I
just have a Malinois you know I just put
him out there no one's coming on my
property that's that's the that's the
real answer you know I'm I'm only half
kidding about the auto defense turrets
we probably won't do that we'll probably
just get dogs but I think you're on to
something though I think eventually
there's going to be something like that
and with technology or a drone imagine a
drone imagine putting your drone up and
you have some thoughts you know the
reason I think the dog is probably the
better bet is because not only can they
help protect the perimeter of your house
but you can give them belly Rubes yeah
dogs are nice well you let me know when
you're ready for a Malinois you got to
be ready for them and be prepared to do
the right training yeah they don't make
for pets do you have a male or a female
male let's talk okay
Sony I love that dog he's a beast I'll
show you her when uh we when we come
down after after the show oh she's here
too yeah Brett Sonny once uh did a good
job uh and uh probably breed him again
soon yeah the one I have now is super
smart
you have to really when it comes to
these dogs uh trainers are so important
absolutely like lawyers like you need a
good lawyer you need a good dog training
yeah
nine trainers let's read some more we
got ready to rumble says National
Geographic says Gen X is 1962 to 1982.
foreign
you guys are the same generation it's up
to us Sam you uh Samurai says gen Z is
the first generation to not watch Looney
Tunes
that's not true I loved Looney Tunes I
hated 79. I absolutely duck I watched it
yeah Looney Tunes Saturday mornings like
you were talking about yeah no I liked
uh Saturday mornings I liked uh X-Men
and and Pokemon I think Pokemon's on
Sunday I can't remember in my area
that's past my time Pokemon my son's
watched um that torch should be gone to
those Pokemon movies you know I I
stopped watching it after Ash lost the
Pokemon League
and I was really angry you know I was a
little kid and I was just like he lost
like did you save any of those Pokemon
cards uh no I lost him on the train when
I was a kid uh yeah all my magic cards
too oh I had time Vault all at once all
at once in a backpack there weren't
money now my son oh yeah yeah we got we
have magic the Gathering cards yesterday
actually yeah with uh very dark yeah
that was fun I was reminded how
imbalanced the game is yeah I just
obserized us twice totally obliterated
yeah wiped it wipe the floor with them
the power creeps yeah it was it was a
power artifact on a Gran on a on a on a
grim monolith yeah and then I had uh
yeah so many other things you had your
cards magic or any of that no no Magic's
awesome nah yeah it's it's a blackjack
yeah yeah poker uh I like Landon I like
Oldham that's a game you guys ever play
hand and foot it's like Canasta yeah
hand and foot all right here we go guy
all good says Ian love you but you don't
know Squad about Islam Ramadan happens
during a lunar month so it is about 29
days earlier each calendar year stick to
what you know all religions fast details
differ yeah yeah I think the the word
Ramadan means burning or searing heat so
that made me think that it originated in
a time of searing heat
um but like you said it could be in a
different month I really don't know that
that much into it so thank you all right
humble JN says Tim cast crew how
confident are you that there is no
infiltrated Personnel in the company
also it would be awesome if you guys can
invite Amir
sarfati if not look up uh if not look up
his videos on YouTube behold Israel
um infiltrated personnel
no idea don't even know how you would
deal with that but uh my thing is
basically this look
I don't have a personal computer like
there's only work machines and when I
get up and do my show the only thing
that I do on it is read the news and
then do reporting so there's like not a
whole lot the issue though with any
company is that you know people can line
make stuff up and they can compromise
your security by sharing details that
seemingly are innocuous and so you know
I have to constantly remind people
people don't understand this right that
if if you're working somewhere that's
under a security threat and you give
someone information as simple as oh yeah
so-and-so took the garbage out that can
be used against you so when you have
people that are like I don't care who
it's meaningless that causes very
serious security problems and we don't
we can't tolerate that
that basically the uh
when we had uh the the issues that we've
had with swatting that the only ones
that have been serious have been due to
like information leaks
so
that's the only thing I'm worried about
yeah I mean uh I I don't think the
commenter is wrong
personally
but
you can't do anything about it maybe
maybe you can uh you know write it down
all this piece of paper and hand it to
me and said just keep it to yourself I
don't keep anything to myself all my
crazy ideas out on here on the show you
know that
cheddar cheddar Bob says it's a big
Super Chat he says an escalator can
never be broken just temporarily
temporarily stairs but I'm sorry Cheddar
Bob that's not correct it can be broken
I've seen the videos where the guy walks
on this on this escalator and then
starts falling down and then people
start getting like crushed and stuff so
yeah I've seen it work you know
yeah they break it's bad
Alex Hilbert says I work in military
Intel most military Intel is just
telling the commander where enemy tanks
are and what not but there are people
that use it to get their foot in the
door in agencies watch out for them hmm
all right Dan Stanger says about Christy
gnome SD governor for president question
mark I don't know what do you guys think
Chrissy gnome is a president I don't
know anything about her yeah same I
don't know Florida wants presidential
uh I don't she might have it stay about
it right but she's got some competition
maybe you know how many more terms how
many more years are left in her term and
it's is it her first term does she have
another one
I really don't know I think more
Governors should just follow what
governor DeSantis is doing and there'd
be rock stars just like him do what the
people want Common Sense really that's
what he's doing in Florida
the real Hydro says again with the
cliche BS well you guys may never want
to post a picture of your kids good luck
stopping your wife
let me let me just say that um
I'm I'm pretty sure as it pertains to
like I don't know the the three of us
here you know
we're the more Cavalier about being
publicly exposed and our significant
others are substantially more concerned
with being private so I'm not worried
about that and it's a that's like a
unified front thing between me and my
spouse how what we do with our kids
pictures I appreciate the sentiment
I really don't bother you know I post
pictures I'm not really worried about
the public it's the babies in this
Modern Age It's the babies when your
kids are a little girl I'm in
grandfather stage if my kids ever
married I don't know I doubt it I don't
know I'm I'm getting really jealous
right here born Mexican raised in
America said Tim I spent my summers in
Mexico I had fresh goat milk and fresh
grilled goat and beef there is nothing
like fresh hearing this takes me back I
am jealous but we do have we're
surrounded by Farms here yep I drive for
five minutes and I can get Farm Fresh
steaks tenderloins you know whatever
bacon the farm bacon you can't the farm
milk you can't drink it says pet milk
and they say you can't drink it wink and
then people just I've tasted it it's
pretty tasty it's great yeah it tastes
very different the store-bought milk is
is weird pasty garbage it's it's so I
remember the first time I had real milk
is because I went to Europe
and American milk is like Bland and flat
is it the pasteurization that destroys
the flavor it has to be garbage diet and
who even drinks milk because people even
drink it I remember when I was a kid it
was like everyone was drinking yeah now
it's like you rarely see people drinking
milk anyway I basically chug a whole
thing of heavy whipping cream every day
I'm exaggerating by the way but uh uh I
use heavy cream I don't use milk milk
much good fat for you yeah I put in my
coffee cut out the sugars increase the
fats all that good stuff good stuff did
well
where we at we'll grab some more Super
Chat says per usual
Scala Brickman says I'd love to see an
episode dedicated to picking Ian's brain
he seems so fluid on everything I can't
figure out what he thinks uh on on in
that regard I have bad news The Bryson
gray episode was uh did not record
tragic tragic no it's true it actually
is pretty tragic because Bryce and I
went for about an hour and a half we had
an amazing conversation about Judaism
Kellen you were here with us for the
second half there yeah yeah it is quite
something it was a good but there's an
audio glitch about 15 minutes in and
this the setting wasn't right on on the
OBS it didn't come out very good so I
think we're gonna scrap it there's
probably is there anything no yeah so
Bryce off of no audio Bryce and I owe
you another conversation man that was
great we'll do it again and yes we
should pick my brain more often I agree
thank you well we never did the you and
Sheamus conversation
what's going on actually I think Shane
Cashman might be oh yeah Shane Cashman
have you met Shane seen any of his work
he's like uh I mean the closest thing to
Hunter S Thompson that the world has
right now yeah but he's like I think
he's clean and sober with a beautiful
family and like like a normal guy that
was like if Hunter made it out yeah yeah
Hunter made it out all right here we go
Christopher Kinley says hey all my band
America American Dharma is playing in
Baltimore Maryland at Zan West next
Friday December 16th doors at seven come
on out and rock with us I think we're
flying to Phoenix
I think we're going to be in Phoenix for
uh for turning point that week so we
won't I don't think we'll be around but
uh direct flights from Phoenix to my
Ranch if you guys want to come out oh
man it's going to be this this next week
is just I'm sorry this next this month
is going to be crazy it's it not only is
it Christmas and and work slows down
because everyone's with family we're
also increasing our workload flying out
to Phoenix we're going to do this event
with turning point it's going to be
awesome when is it the uh uh uh so the
not the next this next week we're here
and the week after that we're in Phoenix
for the Turning Point event yeah it's on
the 17th they got a great off I've been
out there the with Turning Point yeah
we're gonna do IRL on stage cool yeah
that'll be great for you guys I got a
good good bunch of kids in that
organization it's going to be I think
they said 15 000 people it's gonna be
weird I was like is it can can they
handle sitting there for two hours do we
just like shoot the [ __ ] and talk gives
you hope 15 000 conservative kids
getting together yeah man that's great
stuff yeah you see these numbers right
now 25 000 people listening 29 you got
but then and we see it in real life like
yeah whoa all right in person mid MTB
fishyack says The Merchant of death was
entrapped by the de uh entrapped by the
DEA he had never committed a crime
punishable within the USA until said
entrapment stopped the tyranny well I
don't know a whole lot about that so um
thanks for the Super Chat all right
let's uh we'll grab one more Super Chat
Juan Rio says dogs with bees in their
mouths and when they bark they shoot
bees at you that's a great Simpsons
reference my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com to support our
work directly and help us build this
parallel economy I'm really excited
because I think we're going to be
launching this Cafe community space game
shop in the next few months and it's a
beautiful place it's going to be really
really fun I'm really excited for this
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Andrew do you want to shout anything out
uh just I want to wish you luck on that
new Venture and I'll be in Bradford
County Florida January 4th I'll probably
be on Fox that day they're going to
cover the event Cavuto
um and I'm just happy to be here and
shoot the shoot the crap with you guys
all right nice to see some nice young
men making a business for themselves
appreciate you all the luck what was
your Twitter again Andrew Pollock FL
Andrew thank you so much for coming on
that was a really uh awesome
conversation my website is Luke
uncensored.com I did a very interesting
video about coffee and a lot of other
stuff including the topic that got
everyone talking two days ago on this
channel you want to learn about that
plus a lot more Luke uncensored.com uh
thank you guys so much for having me Ian
thanks for having me too man
um great to see you dude thanks uh
thanks again for everything and the
expertise on the show too that's really
cool uh and people will ask where can
they find your organization yeah uh what
was you have a website berna.com and I I
suggest to every parent out there
that's g b y r n a.com go on there this
whole school safety uh platform that I I
list for parents to look at their
children's school to make sure it's safe
and go out and buy some products for
your kids go buy that BGR that bad guy
repellent there's no reason why any
college student after you saw that one
what what state was that uh Idaho and
then that woman too that got uh on the
highway somewhere she got killed
recently but there's no reason why uh
anyone shouldn't be carrying this bad
guy repellent keeping it on you and uh
and just you know always have your head
on a swivel we're illegal
some states are uh pretty bad with it
but uh but there's states where you
can't concealed carry and those are the
states you got to really look out for
your own uh protection because at least
we know sometimes they're not going to
show up thank you so much again for
coming Andrew um Kelly thank you guys
good to see you but happy Friday
everybody uh thanks for coming on the
show I will add your Twitter handle in
the description of all the clips that I
do if that's okay with you that way
people they come and find you and go on
a burner but thanks for letting me hang
out everybody it's been a it's been a
good Friday all right everybody thanks
for hanging out we're gonna have Clips
up throughout the weekend and we will
see you all on Monday